The Last of Us is one of the most iconic
exclusives in the PlayStation catalog
it's genuinely hard to ignore this game
given how much discussion has spawned
from it even as someone like myself
who's played Xbox games throughout most
of their life even I couldn't escape it
I've heard for many years how good the
series was and with the show just
recently coming to a close I figured now
was a better time than ever to see what
it's all about and similar to what I
said in my God of War video playing it
was one of the greatest decisions I've
ever made these games have made me feel
things I hadn't felt before when I was
fully invested in the story its world
and its characters and today I want to
talk about why as usual the plan for the
video is to not only explain the story
of The Last of Us you have a better
understanding of what's going on but
also be critiquing it along the way we
discussing things such as whether or not
the story had any plot holes whether or
not the scene had invoked the emotions
it intended and of course at its most
basic level was the story even any good
so without further Ado let's get started
as games get older more and more
opinions start to form over the years
I've heard many great things about part
1. some have said its gameplay is
engaging and its story is captivating
others have said it's a fantastic
PlayStation exclusive and so good that
you should buy a PlayStation just to
play this game I've even heard people go
as far as to say that part 1 is the
greatest game ever made I want to start
off this section by saying that all of
this is 100 True while it wouldn't
personally rank it as the greatest game
ever made I could see the argument for
it and would not be surprised if they
showed up on someone else's top 10 list
part 1 was such a breath of fresh air as
it's been some time since I've played a
game that is made of such high quality I
think book continues to blow my mind
about this whole ordeal is that it was
just one game that caused all of this
these feelings that people have about
the series came immediately after it was
released this wasn't something that
started off slow but eventually grew on
people as more entries came in this was
a hit from the very beginning and I'm
amazed at how incredible the story of
this game is when all it's really about
is a man and his surrogate daughter but
I'm getting a bit ahead of myself we
have to start from the very beginning
when it was just a man and his actual
daughter
The Last of Us at the moment takes place
in 2013 and right away we're introduced
to two characters our main protagonist
Joel Miller and his daughter Sarah
already though we can start to see some
of that impeccable quality part one
really excels at conveying the tone of a
scene without using words it can also
tell us how characters feel and interact
without being blatantly obvious in this
scene Sarah is woken up by Joel who
realizes that she only has a few minutes
to give Joel his presence since it's his
birthday child is pleased to receive the
gift but the two joke around a bit by
having Joel trick Sarah into thinking
that the watch is broken which is Then
followed up by Sarah's comment about
having to sell hardcore drugs in order
to afford the watch you can tell from
this short conversation that the two
have a deep love for each other as any
father and daughter would Sarah then
falls asleep only to be woken up again
but this time by her uncle Tommy Tommy
says that he needs to talk to Joel
immediately so we have to go find him
while searching the house for Joel I
started to develop a deep appreciation
for this game's attention to detail as
throughout the house are items we can
pick up that let us get a glimpse of the
world of The Last of Us it felt like
things in this world were put in here
with care and consideration pictures of
Joel and Sarah at a soccer game are sat
next to soccer balls and posters all
these items give us an idea as to who
Sarah is without the game actually
telling us furthermore there are a
couple of newspapers and a TV broadcast
that give us a tease of the events to
come at the moment there's an infection
going around that seems to be spreading
far enough for it to be considered a
pandemic people aren't required to
quarantine yet but there are some
growing concerns regarding what the
future of the world could look like
there is a very obvious low-hanging
fruit of a joke here I'm not gonna take
it in all seriousness this outbreak
seems to be spreading faster than we
think as there are not only cops and
explosions going off around the area but
once we find Joel we watch as he defend
Sarah from their neighbor who he thinks
is very sick the incredibly astute
observation aside Joel and Sarah decided
to leave the house just in time for
Tommy to come by and pick them up
continuing the theme of portraying a
character's emotions and feelings
without being blunt about it the trio
finds a family on the side of the road
Tommy wants to pull over and help them
but Joel tells them to keep driving
Tommy wanted to help the families and
they have a kid with them but Joel is
only focused on his family just after
this Tommy is stuck on the road as
people are pouring out of buildings and
running for their lives Tommy doesn't
want to drive anywhere though since he's
worried that he'll run someone over Joel
couldn't care less
it's not that Joel is a heartless person
it's just that he's pragmatic he only
cares about his family and if he has to
leave someone behind that he doesn't
know or drive through some people then
so be it the town has turned into a
doggy dog kind of world and trust me you
do not want to be eaten they then end up
getting into a car accident and have to
run on foot Joel and Sarah will
eventually have to leave Tommy behind
and end up meeting with a soldier
but
yes sir
somebody we've just been through hell
okay we just need
oh no
sir
move your hands big
I know baby I know
listen man you're gonna be okay baby
stay with me
I'll pick you up
come on baby please I know baby I know
Sarah
[Music]
baby
I'm sorry for those who have seen this
already and I had to put you through
that again but I needed to play for
those who haven't seen it before that
scene is rough the whimpering from Sarah
as she bleeds to death is painful to sit
through I remember just sitting in
silence for a few minutes because I was
so shocked at what I just heard now I've
heard a lot about this series over the
last nine years so I knew this scene was
coming but this is the first time I've
actually heard the scene in full and it
was still a gut-wrenching experience
what really sold the scene was Sarah as
her voice acting was incredible Naughty
Dog the team behind the game really
wants you to feel Joel's pain in this
moment he just lost his daughter and
anyone with an ounce of empathy could
understand the pain he's going through I
personally am not a parent and don't
plan on being one for a while so I don't
have any kids of my own but I felt that
pain that Joel was feeling at that
moment because it's not just some guy
losing his daughter it's someone losing
the person he loves most and that is
definitely something everyone can relate
to in terms of the prologue as a whole I
can't think of a better way to start the
game the slow build up to the first
infections the eventual chaos that
ensues is very stereotypical but it's
handled perfectly here making the player
run through these streets also heightens
the player's agency you're not watching
the world crumble in front of you you
are in that crumbling world and are
forced to run through it Sarah dying is
also extremely important as the reason
the events of the story unfold the way
they do could technically be attributed
to this moment right here overall it's
just a great first impression and
succeeds in hooking the player in
immediately that being said this is a
game after all so the player also needs
to be hooked by the gameplay of the game
which by the following section focuses a
bit more on that but they do need to set
the scene a little bit as we do skip 20
years ahead as with Mo zombie
apocalypses the infection got worse over
time rather than better which is why the
world is in shambles goals also
noticeably older and has managed to
partner up with someone called Tess
during these 20 years both she and Joel
have been doing smuggling runs for
various people these things they're
smuggling involve Goods Contraband ammo
ration cards or whatever they need at
the moment in terms of their
relationship I never got the sense that
they were anything more than friends
they have known each other for quite a
while and test on occasion harmlessly
flirts with Joel but both of them seem
to have that survival of the fittest
mentality so while it's possible that
they may have feelings for each other
it's ultimately not important as
survival is all they care about however
that doesn't mean that they don't care
about each other at all because Joel
clearly cares about Tess's whereabouts
and was worried that she was hurt during
her recent deal this deal was something
that the two of them were supposed to
handle together but Tess went alone
thankfully everything went okay but
after the deal was made Tess got jumped
by some thugs apparently these goons
were sent by a guy named Robert someone
the two are very familiar with given the
state of the world it's not like the two
have a nine to five to go to so you know
no time like the present this then leads
into a 40 to 50 minute chapter that is
pretty much a tutorial but a lot of
story can be learned from this lengthy
Mission from this we can see the sad
world that is the last of us as each
area within this quarantine zone is
split up into places called areas some
like the one Joel and Tesla event are in
decent condition given the circumstances
but the next area over where Robert is
located is filled with trash dirt and
all manner of questionable individuals
people don't want to talk to others
unless they have business and some guy
is selling dogs nearby likely for
protection but I could also Imagine
people buying them to make food Joel and
Tess's area isn't without problems
either as rations are running low
someone was just executed in the street
because they were infected and a bombing
just occurred moments after the people
that started this bombing are called the
fireflies the fireflies are a militia
faction that opposes the rule of the
military these bombings seem to be quite
common as we heard about another Firefly
bombing in the intro credits so they
seem to be some kind of terrorist
organization that is fed up with the
military's rule on the people at this
moment in the game though I kind of
found the fireflies to be quite boring
as they don't really have a clear
motivation this will change once we get
to the Final Chapter but still even
after beating the game I found it quite
hard to care about them as they never
really got much screen time besides the
major events at the end they seem to be
a faction that is trying to be the good
guys but in a world like The Last of Us
anyone can consider themselves the good
guys especially when the opening crawl
literally states that the government is
gone and that the military is taken over
so no faction is really considered good
they believe that they're good because
their viewpoints are opposites of that
of their enemies given the point of this
game's story which as we'll see is about
Joel and a girl named Ellie I can
understand why naughty dog wanted to
tell a more personal story but I do
think some more info on the fireflies
and the military would have been nice as
well that being said while we don't
learn too much about them we do get to
see some of their operations first hand
as after Joel and Tess find Robert Tess
puts a bullet in him for doing them
dirty before meeting with Marlene the
current leader of the fireflies this is
some incredible timing as Robert had
taken some of tests in Joel's guns and
then sold them to the fireflies the duo
wants them back but since Marlene
already paid for them they have to
strike a deal Marlene wants them to
smuggle something out of the zone to one
of their camps that it can be taken to
their lab that being Ellie a 14 year old
girl as creepy and concerning as that
sounds will eventually learn that the
reason they want her at their lab is
because Ellie is immune to the infection
which is a perfect time to talk about
what this infection actually is so the
infection of the last of us is called
cordyceps however unlike some media
where it starts with with a virus
cordyceps is actually a fungal infection
it functions like a typical zombie virus
would and that bites will turn someone
into an infected but there were two
distinct details related to this that I
found extremely fascinating that being
that it's based on a real world fungus
and that the infection is based on time
the cordyceps of The Last of Us is based
on the real-life fungus ophiocordyceps
unilaterus this is a fungus that usually
infects ants however other variations of
cordyceps prey on other insects as well
in this case an infected ant can be
easily identified as it's brought a
small Branch with what looks like a
fruit attached to it once infected the
fungus compels the ant to basically find
a branch and hook onto it forever it
lockjaws its mandibles to hold on tight
because that Branch will eventually
Sprout from its head once it sprouts
spores released from the top and spread
across the ground in air infecting other
ants there's actually a clip of this
process in BBC's planet Earth series
that I'll leave in the description I was
going to show it but I know some of you
may not want to look at some Dead
Infected insects neodruckerman the
creative director for the series took a
liking to the fungus it was based around
numbers meaning the more ants there were
the deadlier it becomes because one
becomes four then four becomes 16 and so
on until they're all wiped out but while
Neil liked the disease for its
zombie-like qualities I'm more
fascinated with how he managed to change
it in the game using time the cordyceps
fungus has multiple stages and these
stages depend on how long someone has
been infected the first stage is the
runner stage these are your typical
zombie infected blood red eyes thirst
for flesh all that good stuff this
usually occurs within a day or two of
being infected after a week or so the
fungus starts to grow and they hit stage
2 called stalkers the only visual
difference is the small amount of fungus
growing out from their body once we hit
a year though we start getting into some
dangerous territory as they start to
become clickers clickers are blind but
have incredible hearing they're also
extremely tough as they're the first
form of the infection so far that can
one shot the player if not careful if a
clicker gets too close even at full
health you die immediately the only way
to save yourself is a skill in the game
that allows you to stab a clicker with a
shiv before they bite you after a few
years of the cordyceps infection these
clickers will eventually become bloaters
the final stage of the infection at
least within the bounds of the first
game bloaters can also One-Shot the
player with the added bonus of being
able to throw the fungus from afar and
are incredibly strong or possibly immune
to damage if they aren't hit in their
fungal weak spots since the clickers and
bloaters need some time in order to be
created it's no wonder why we find them
in areas with either hundreds of other
infected or in these small spore-filled
rooms these spores are toxic to the
human body which is why survivors need
gas masks in order to Traverse them it's
unclear what happens when you inhale
these but it's safe to assume you still
contract the infection given it works
the same way as the real cordyceps
I absolutely love the way Naughty Dog
handled this from a gameplay point of
view as it makes the stronger enemies
actually strong given they can one shot
the player but from a story point of
view it's a unique version of
environmental storytelling since the
infection is based on time we can deduce
what happened in certain areas depending
on that factor for example much later in
the game we end up entering a university
and in here are a few clickers and one
bloater this means that these people
were likely students of the university
and that they were infected over a year
ago furthermore the absence of newly
formed Runners also implies that either
no one has entered this building since
then or that they did but managed to
escape
this idea can then be used to determine
research-rich environments if an area is
infested with a ton of clickers that
means a lot of people died here but that
also means no one's been here in over a
year meaning no one has scavenged it for
its resources now given that the
infection was 20 years ago it's not a
foolproof plan but still I like the
implications that can be derived from
this concept just from that summary
alone it's pretty clear that it infected
on its own is incredibly strong and
that's not even considering the times
that they're all grouped together but
how's that old saying go kill it with
fire well that brings true here in the
last of us as fire is your best friend
in any situation if you don't have any
fire though a stealth kill will work on
just about everything minus a bloater
this connects to the gameplay of The
Last of Us which is just downright
fantastic basically it's a mix of
survival and stealth being quiet is the
way to go as while going loud doesn't
guarantee death you will die much faster
you're also forced to scavenge for items
in ammo as you can craft things like
shivs in health packs prolonging your
life
the gameplay is in perfect sync with the
story as Joel is running through
unfamiliar territory most of the time so
Scavenging and making sure you have the
proper equipment at all times is
critical plus it's a post-apocalypse So
Random scrapping gear is laid out all
over the place this is unlike other
games like Left 4 Dead where guns and
ammo are everywhere and crafting items
are non-existent now obviously left for
dead and the last of us are trying to be
two totally different games so
admittedly it's on a great comparison
but you get my point what you think
people would be doing in a
post-apocalypse is exactly what you'll
be doing in the last of us it's
incredibly realistic and makes for some
engaging combat since ammo is not
plentiful sometimes you'll have 10 to 20
rounds and be on the top of the world
sometimes though all you'll have is a
wooden 2x4 since all your ammo is gone
it's a fantastic Survival game and maybe
even a survival horror game since this
game can really scare the [__] out of
you sometimes Jokes Aside the gameplay
was engaging enough to keep me on my
toes from beginning to end and it's in
perfect sync with the story which is
always a plus
getting back on track we have to talk
about Ellie as I stated earlier Ellie is
immune this is shown To Us by her as she
got bit a few weeks ago and yet feels
completely fine the fireflies want to
take her to their lab so they can
possibly manufacture a cure as Ellie
seems to be one of a kind Joel and Tess
are intrigued by the idea of a cure but
as we know they aren't the type of
people to place it above their actual
goal of survival so while they will
accept the job the reason is likely
because they want their gear back once
they make it outside though both Joel
and Tess get into an argument Tess is
starting to believe the claim Ellie made
about being immune but Joka care less he
thinks the outside is dangerous and that
they shouldn't even be here if there was
one major criticism I had with this game
it said it's the supposed plot twists
aren't exactly subtle while I did just
say it's a major complaint it's only
major because I don't have much to
criticize about this game since in
reality it's just a small part of the
game that only happens twice to explain
what I mean after Joel Tess and Ellie
get through a large wave of infected
test starts to look ticked off for some
reason it's then revealed a few minutes
later that she was bit is going to turn
I feel like this was supposed to be made
out as quite the twist as our teammate
is going to die yet it wasn't exactly
hard to tell given her Sudden Change of
attitude just to reiterate this only
happens twice throughout the game and is
by far my biggest complaint of part 1
which just goes to show how good this
game is if something this small is my
biggest issue that's why I called the
game a breath of fresh air earlier since
it's nice to be able to just sit back
and gush about a game without having to
talk about something that bothered me
because honestly not much else really
did for example Ellie herself is
fantastic and is now one of my favorite
Side characters in gaming period Ellie's
going to be with us for the rest of the
game and getting tests out of the
picture was likely intended so the
player could get more one-on-one time
with Ellie we'll meet a few Side
characters like Tess throughout the game
but a good 90 of the experience is just
Joel and Ellie this is critical because
that's the whole point of this game it's
not about the zombie outbreak it's about
these two right here where some games
use the outbreak as the main motivator
the last of us use it as a backdrop as
it influences the rest of the story in
the background if the The Last of Us was
like other games and the plot of the
story would be to escort Ellie to the
fireflies in order to get the Cure that
is of course what we do but I wouldn't
say that's the plot it's just an
objective that is used to move the story
forward the plot is the relationship
between Ellie and Joel it might be a bit
hard to understand but the best example
I can give is God of War 2018. in that
game the objective that drives the story
forward is delivering the ashes of
kratos's wife Faye what's more important
though is the interactions Kratos and
atres have throughout the game and how
they go from a broken relationship to a
repaired one The Last of Us is similar
in that respect as we're embarking on a
journey with Ellie and the interactions
the two have are the most important part
of the game that's why just like with
atreus Naughty Dog needed to make sure
you care about Ellie in the first place
and they absolutely succeeded in doing
so Ellie is brimming with life and is
full of personality and she is the
complete opposite of Joel which
complements him quite well Joel is an
adult-born pre-outbreak who's always
pragmatic and very serious Ellie is a
child born after the outbreak who's very
naive and more light-hearted the two
could be further apart if they tried
which is what makes the relationship so
intriguing Joel teaches Ellie how to
survive in the harsh world of the last
of us but thanks to Ellie's personality
rubbing off on him he starts to be more
open with her being more like a father
and less like a stranger job will end up
telling Ellie about the world before the
outbreak since Ellie has never known a
world without the cordyceps he'll teach
her about the rules of football and
explain to her what an ice cream truck
was these are completely foreign
Concepts to her due to the outbreak
changing the world furthermore the game
has what is called optional
conversations these are small talk
stolen Ellie will have about certain
topics such as this one time when Ellie
asks why the girl on the poster is so
skinny to which draw replies that some
people just didn't eat so that they
could look that way to Ellie this is
strange since food is a delicacy in the
world post outbreak but sometimes
they're not just talks but full-on
interactions like later in the game when
we meet two people called Henry and Sam
if you enter this one house and stay
long enough Ellie and Sam will play
darts for a bit before leaving the two
of them will also reenact a penalty shot
a bit later when they find a ball on a
net in one of the hideouts there are so
many of these interactions that just add
so much depth and personality tally that
we could be here all day if I wanted to
I'll spare you most of the details but
still hearing all of these interactions
really makes you appreciate their
inclusion
foreign
are you all right
I'm trying to learn how to whistle
you don't know how to whistle it doesn't
sound like I know how to whistle
I'm whistling
oh good
something else you can drive me crazy
with
[Music]
yeah sure Joe go ahead take my cards
take all my food too while you're at it
by the looks of it you could lose some
of that food listen to me you little
[__] [__] you you I need you to shut up
all right okay you guys are killing me
with your Downer talk it's joke book
time what is that just bear with me
[Music]
you want to hear a joke about pizza
never mind it was too cheesy I don't get
it yeah me neither
what did the green grapes say to the
purple grape
breathe you idiot
so stupid
but Ellie isn't just great from a story
point of view but also from a gameplay
one as well the problem with making a
supporting character that follows the
player around is that you don't want to
give them too much control or the player
will feel like the side character unless
that's intentional of course but on the
opposite end too little control or power
makes them feel useless by far the best
example of a supporting character that I
can think of is Elizabeth from BioShock
Infinite she will help the player by
opening up tears in the map allowing you
to summon cover or weapons which will
also give you ammo and vigor if you're
low she doesn't do any actual killing
but her assistance is incredibly helpful
as for Ellie in the beginning she's
actually quite useless but that's
because Joel doesn't trust her
eventually though he starts to feel more
comfortable which is around the time the
game gives her the ability to knife some
enemies and even give her a pistol once
those come into play though she starts
to be a valuable asset to the team one
part I vividly remember is when I was
stupidly sneaking up on this two-man
group in hindsight I should have just
let them pass but I choked the one out
anyway the guy next to him saw me but
before he could shoot Ellie was already
taking care of him and saved my life now
ignoring the fact that the guy had a
shotgun and for some odd reason decided
to get farther away from me before
shooting this is just one example of a
Time Ellie had helped me throughout the
game just like how many RPGs such as
mass effect and Dragon Age have
consciously make you care about your
companions by having them help you in
combat and by also giving you enough
down time to talk to them you start to
feel more connected to Ellie through
those exact methods which is extremely
important as once again the entire story
hinges on the fact that you even
remotely care about her and I think
naughty dog did an incredible job at
doing so once it's revealed that Tess is
bit she tells Joel and Ellie to leave
while she distracts the military guards
that are coming to kill them from
escaping The Zone Tess attempts to fend
them off but is eventually put down Joel
and Ellie then escaped into the subway
station and we can see that not only can
Ellie not turn when bitten but she can
also breathe in the spores without any
issue once they escape Joel says that
they'll be traveling north a bit as
there's a town there with someone who
may have a car this is also the first
time the game has started adding more
color to a lot of its environment as
we've gone from a collapse cityscape to
a town with a lush Forest on the topic
of Graphics the game looks great and
it's probably pretty obvious by now but
I'm playing on the remastered version if
I'm being honest the only reason I chose
this option was because it was cheaper
the last of us has an original remaster
and remake version the Remake version
definitely looks the best but it
received a bit of flack on release
remaster usually means a technical
upgrade things like 60fps accessibility
features and other graphical additions
are added in these versions a remake
typically means a definitive change from
the original whether that be its
gameplay or story I haven't played the
Remake personally but it just seems to
be a remaster of a remaster however most
of these complaints are likely from
current fans of the series which is
totally valid but as a new player this
doesn't really apply to me if you're
hopping into the series for the first
time both the remaster and remake
versions are great options if the
question was what version should I play
then I would say that all the options
are worth it but if the question was
should I pay 70 for a game that has
another version that is a third of the
price and is readily accessible from the
digital PlayStation Store
well I think the version I'm playing
will give you my answer once the two
make it inside the town Joel ends up
getting caught in a trap before being
rescued by Bill Bill is the man Joel was
looking for and he's kind of a nut case
at times he talks to himself quite a bit
and has various traps laid out
throughout the town side now one can
enter he's very particular about his
work traps and Equipment this is likely
due to his long-term isolation there is
no one in the town but Bill by the time
we arrive it's unclear if there were
people here but all of them died except
for Bill or he just took residence in an
already destroyed town but has been
living here for quite some time one
thing we do know though is that there
used to be another Resident here called
Frank who Bill considered a dear friend
and partner when we find Frank we see
that he has hung himself in one of the
houses here in the town according to our
conversations with Bill it seems like he
and Frank were lovers at one point but
it seems like Frank grew increasingly
tired of Bill's methods of survival and
decided to leave town it's unclear if
Frank left but then immediately got bit
or just went to another part of town and
stayed there for a while but we do know
that he stole some of Bill's equipment
and even in a car battery so it seems
like he had planned on leaving the town
at some point but ended up getting
bitten before that happened this section
of the game also highlights another
great part about the last of us even
though these characters were only with
us for a couple of hours it hurts to see
them go it's nice to be able to interact
and talk with other characters from time
to time but when they leave the void
that was left behind is ever present
even though bill was less than pleased
with my arrival it was nice to be able
to speak with him and see how he managed
to survive in this harsh world but now
that we have the car we're not going to
be seeing him again after getting the
car Joel and Ellie with the help of Bill
managed to get it running and the duo
drives to Pittsburgh the welcoming party
though is anything but welcoming as the
first people we meet are two Hunters it
seems like a large group of Bandits have
taken over the Pittsburgh Highway which
means getting out of here and back on
the road is going to be difficult as the
two Traverse through broken buildings
filled with stores hotels and other
shops Joel ends up getting attacked by
one of the bandits
oh
I shot the hell out of that guy huh
he sure did
I feel sick
and you just hang back like I told you
to
well you're glad I didn't right
I'm glad I didn't get my head blown off
by a goddamn kid
you know what no
how about hey Ellie I I know it wasn't
easy but it was either him or me thanks
for saving my ass you got anything like
that for me Joel it's a bit hard to tell
since the gameplay can be quite divorced
from the story at times plus Ellie
usually does a lot of things off screen
so it's unclear if this is her first
kill but if we just base it off the
story and cut scenes alone this is the
first time she's killed someone that
isn't an infected as you would expect
this takes a toll on her which is why
she says that she feels sick I really
like the attention to detail here as
taking a human life can be a very
traumatic experience no matter the
context however this is kind of soured
by the fact that Ellie is given a rifle
about 15 minutes later and then proceeds
to mow down quite a few Bandits with no
issue but other than that it's a really
great scene although I did like how
before the shooting began Joel was
teaching her the basics of shooting like
how to reload and where to put the rifle
stock so that the recoil doesn't knock
the gun out of her hand it shows that
Joel is starting to open up more and
Trust Ellie eventually after narrowly
escaping another group of Bandits riding
around in a truck the two then meet
Henry and Sam just just like build these
two are a pair of survivors that have
been trying to make do you can tell that
their relationship was created this way
on purpose as Henry and Sam are similar
to Joel and Ellie except instead of a
father and daughter it's two brothers
it's not the exact same situation but
Henry and Joel are both adults who want
to make sure their younger partner is
safe and Ellie and Sam are both kids so
they have another person to talk to
about kid stuff instead of having to
listen to the adults all the time Henry
will also at one point tell San that he
can't take the toy he found with him
because the backpack is only for
Essentials his attitude and personality
are very similar to that of Joel's in
the sense that all that matters is
survival the group then makes it back to
Henry and Sam's Hideout and discuss how
to get out of here as the Bandit patrols
are going to keep coming and sooner or
later they'll be found Henry has been
trying to leave to join the fireflies
but due to them being outnumbered it's
hard to find the right time to go this
works out for Joel since he needs to
find the fireflies anyway since they'll
be taking Ellie to their lab just as he
was told this current chapter and the
following one are around this Middle
Point in the game where you really don't
know what Joel is thinking in regard to
Ellie in in the beginning he was very
much against doing this job and he
didn't even want to leave the Zone even
if she could be used to make a cure now
that Joel's had some more alone time
with Ellie he started to care about her
more but it's still hard to tell if it's
genuine or simply because it's just a
job what's definitely more apparent
though is that he has started to take a
liking to Ellie as he's much different
than he was four chapters ago but this
does not seem to be a one-sided Affair
as while the group is escaping from the
truck we saw earlier they climb a ladder
only for it to snap once Joel climbs up
this in the following scene really
solidified for me that while Joel may be
on the fence in regards to his feelings
about Ellie she most definitely trusts
him instead of going with Henry and Sam
She willingly goes back down to help
Joel later she'll also jump off a bridge
into the water once the two are cornered
prior to this the game tells us that
Ellie can swim it also forces us to find
ways around that problem which is why
multiple puzzles involve dragging her
across the water Ellie will literally
drown if she jumps in here but she
trusts Joe enough to grab her once they
land there was no doubt on my mind at
this point that Ellie had taken a liking
to Joel and started seeing him as more
than just a brutish tough guy that he
was portrayed as in the previous
chapters jumping off the bridge though
did seem like certain death but the two
managed to survive thanks to Henry and
Sam finding them washed up on the shore
Joel is rightfully pissed at the two for
leaving them behind but Henry's
statement of would you have done the
same is a fair point well they are a
group they have only been acquaintances
for some time ultimately Henry only
cares about Sam and Joel only cares
about Ellie they may save each other if
one is being attacked but if they had to
choose they know who they're picking the
four of them will group up and push
through the towns I think closer to
their destination until they're spooked
by some Infected that we're hiding
nearby I don't think I need to spell it
out for you but yeah one of them got bit
and seeing his Sam's attitude starts to
change shortly after this you be correct
in assuming that it's him while the
reveal isn't exactly subtle I did like
how this was handled
Sam decides to hide his bite mark from
everyone for some reason but this came
with the side effect of the cordyceps
turning him into a modern day Socrates
as he starts talking to Ellie about
death and whether or not the people who
are infected are still conscious it's
some thought-provoking stuff sure but
it's very clear that he's only thinking
about this as he's trying to reflect on
his life and come to terms with what's
about to happen another detail that is
quite important and will be referenced
later is that while the two are talking
Sam asks what Ellie fears the most to
which she says being alone everyone then
goes to bed and well what a start to the
morning this is going to be Ellie checks
on Sam and sees that he's bit which
wakes up the others Henry omo shoots
Joel over this because Joel was going to
kill him first Henry knows what he has
to do though and puts down his younger
brother but the initial shock faded as
fast as it came as now Henry realizes
that he just shot Sam which prompts him
to take his own life I'm a bit torn on
whether or not the scene should have
ended this fast as it immediately cuts
to Black and fast forwards to the next
chapter but after mulling it over a bit
I think it works both ways having it
skip right to the next chapter without
any warning forces the player to sit
with it during the black screen rather
than let the scene play out plus it
could even show that not only is death
come in place in this world but that
they have to keep going despite the
circumstances had the scene played out
for a few extra seconds and may be shown
the shocked phases of both Ellie and
Joel I think the intended emotion would
have come out anyway I do personally
like how fast they skipped over it
though since it really does show how
unimportant a single person in this game
is especially if they aren't Joel and
Ellie since their relationship is the
main focus of the story as for where the
journey takes us next will we find
ourselves near Jackson Wyoming because
according to Joel his brother Tommy the
one we saw in the intro is located here
upon arriving we find out that not only
is this true but that Tommy has found
some love in this war-torn world in the
form of Maria and that Joel and Tommy
aren't exactly on good terms Joel and
Tommy after the incident with Sarah
likely worked together to survive but
apparently the two had a falling out due
to some disagreements Tommy eventually
ended up joining the fireflies which is
why Joel was trying to find him but it
seems like he's left that group and is
on his own Joel then wants Tommy to take
Ellie with him to the fireflies
Laboratories that the job can be
finished this day upsets both Tom and
Ellie Tommy has people to protect and in
all fairness it is a bit rude to just
stroll into a settlement and immediately
demand they do something for you but
Ellie is bothered by this because they
mean she'll have to leave Joel behind
and we already know how she feels about
that what are you so afraid of
that I'm going to end up like Sam I
can't get infected I can take care of
myself how many close calls have we had
well we seem to be doing all right so
far and now you'll be doing even better
with Tommy
not her you know what
Maria told me about Sarah Ellie
you are treading awesome Mighty thin
eyes here
I'm sorry about your daughter Joel
but I have lost people too you have no
idea what loss is
everyone I have cared for has either
died or left me
everyone
so don't tell me that I would be safer
with someone else because the truth is I
would just be more scared
foreign this conversation might honestly
be my favorite scene in the game as it's
where the story finally takes a turn
Ellie showed Joel that she cares about
him and won't do this without him this
in turn forces Joel to also consider his
feelings for her and just about all of
us Knew by this point that he does care
about Ellie and that he's starting to
see her more as his daughter rather than
just some kid which is why he decides to
take Ellie to the fireflies himself
instead of having Tommy do it for him he
doesn't want to leave Ellie alone and
Ellie doesn't want to leave without Joel
It's Not only adorable seeing the two
interact with one another but this was
all showcased incredibly well seeing the
relationship then versus now is almost
night and day Joel started out being
annoyed that he has to take a kid with
him on a job and his inability to trust
her made combat more difficult over time
though he does start to trust her more
and more by giving her a weapon to
defend herself Ellie came around much
faster but still in the beginning she
wasn't interested in talking with Joel
and Tess but as things progressed she
started taking a liking to Joel and
realized that not only can she not do
this without him she doesn't want to do
this without him this breakthrough in
their relationship breaks down that
barrier that they had allowing the two
to be more cash with each other Joel
talks to Ellie about football and the
two share what their dream occupations
used to be it all just further confirms
that they really are a perfect
father-daughter Duo even if they're not
related by blood as they approach the
university they start to realize that no
fireflies are here Tommy said that this
is where they were stationed but no
one's here not even infected
unfortunately we don't have too much
time to ponder why that's the case or
where the fireflies went as well Joel's
listening to a recording a group of men
attempt to shoot at him he manages to
fend them off but one of them gets the
jump on him instead of Ellie taking time
to shoot him she just watches as Joel
Falls over the railing onto a piece of
sharp debris Ellie then has to help Joel
Escape before he bleeds out this was
admittedly a short encounter but I
enjoyed this quite a bit the stakes were
high here and it felt like I needed to
be precise with my timing and accuracy
or I was going to fail like right in the
beginning when Ellie goes to distract
the guy approaching me but I needed to
make sure to shoot him once he turns or
he'll kill Ellie this scene also shows
how much Ellie has improved over the
course of the game she's basically
running the show at this point where for
the past seven chapters we've been
protecting her but the game plans to
push this to its limit as Joel ends up
collapsing once they start leaving the
school now Ellie has to do this on her
own before Joel was taking the lead and
even just now Joel was capable of
holding his own but at the moment it's
all her she can't ask Joe for directions
or for help she's the star of the show
now as we could see though she's managed
to handle everything quite well as the
next scene after this is her hunting a
rabbit it's also winter now meaning it's
been quite some time since Joel was
injured Ellie's been surviving for the
both of them for at least a couple weeks
to a month and seems to be doing all
right all things considered but
apparently the game isn't done torturing
her just yet as she ends up running into
a man named David he tells her that he
needs that deer she just shot because
the people he's with are very hungry the
two end up trading food for medicine
since Joel is sick but this bodes ill
for Ellie as David here has actually
been looking for them for quite some
time as those men at the University were
his Ellie manages to make it back to
Joel but is an ambushed and taken the
following morning by David and his men
David to put it bluntly is a creep and
likely a pedophile David says that he
has something special in store for Ellie
and one of them calls her David's new
pet he and his group are also cannibals
as we can see someone cutting off
someone's limbs thankfully Ellie doesn't
give in to any of David's advances and
even takes the opportunity to break one
of his fingers in the process the
question arises though what do we do now
Ellie's locked in a cell and Joel's
injured or is he thanks to Ellie giving
Joel some of the medicine before being
taken Joel manages to muster up enough
strength to stand up and search for
Ellie from this point on the game will
have a switch between Joel and Ellie at
different points before the two finally
come together at the end of the chapter
this was a major contributor as to why I
like the chapter so much it is great
being able to see both characters move
on their own especially when we go
through places as Joel that we just
visited as Ellie knowing that we're
getting closer but we're also still far
behind and we need to get to her before
something happens basically Joel's
sections are about getting to Ellie and
Ellie's are about escaping David and his
men the reason Ellie was even able to
escape is that right before they were
about to cut her up Ellie told him that
she was infected and even though we know
that's not true no one knows she's
immune plus she still has the bite mark
from when it happened while the two
stand around confused Ellie stabbed
James and runs away before David can
shoot her this then leads into that back
and forth we talked about where we play
as both characters before we reach the
climactic fight between David and Ellie
both of them only have melee weapons so
we have to get in close to stab David
but if he catches you then you die
there's also glass scattered all over
the floor which will alert David and
after hitting him once he starts to take
cover which admittedly had me panicking
for a bit because I couldn't find him
for like a solid minute eventually the
tube will fall to the ground and Ellie
has to crawl to the nearby weapon but
David gets to it first I initially
thought this is where Joel would arrive
and save the day but I was quite wrong
look
[Music]
he's trying to oh baby girl
what's up
[Music]
just like before the line delivery and
voice acting are incredible and it
really conveys the emotions these
characters are feeling at this moment
Ellie just went through one of the most
traumatic experiences of her life and
she had to do it all alone Ellie never
knows that Joel was awake until he
arrives so this whole time Ellie felt
like it was her against the world and
when she needed him most Joel wasn't
there obviously this wasn't Joel's fault
but still being forced to go through all
this on her own was traumatizing enough
which is why she lashed out that being
said Ellie was able to hold her own
quite well despite how terrified she may
have been Ellie has already surpassed
many of my favorite Side characters in
other games but seeing her take Center
Stage for a bit not only confirms just
how great of a side character she really
is but it also gave us a very well
developed character Arc for her the
world of The Last of Us is used to push
the characters into unfavorable
scenarios and this whole chapter was
where Ellie was pushed to her limit she
had to do everything on her own and
almost lost Joel in the process she
managed to succeed but stuff like this
won't come without consequences as right
after this we cut the spring and we can
see it the thought of the day is still
on her mind thanks to the symbolism of
the deer on the wall but while the world
made be cruel it can also be very
beautiful as her mood immediately
changes upon seeing a giraffe nearby
since Ellie was born post outbreak
animals like this are like dinosaurs for
us so being able to see one in person is
like a miracle plus it's a giraffe
they're adorable the game like its
pacing handles these mood swings quite
well Ellie just went from butchering a
man to death to petting a giraffe in
about five minutes but it never felt
jarring or out of place Ellie is a kid
so it's not uncommon for her to act like
one and jump at the next thing she sees
right away the game also wants you to
enjoy this moment too by letting you sit
and look at the giraffes with her you're
allowed to leave whenever you want but
if you want to stay then the game will
let you stay it's a very peaceful moment
and after the hours of stress you've
likely had at this point a peaceful
moment is very much needed
this moment also prompts Joel to bring
up their journey to Ellie he asks her if
this is something she really wants to do
he's totally fine with turning back and
going to Jackson if that's what she
wants Joel is really only here for Ellie
and doesn't care what happens he just
wants to make sure that this is
something she wants to do because
technically this was Marlene's idea and
she might have felt inclined to go
because of her once you've seen enough
of the animals you can leave the
building which prompts Ellie to give
Joel a picture of Sarah and him together
this was the same photo we saw back at
Joel's house in the intro and it also
reappears during the chapter with Tommy
as he says that he went back to their
home in Texas and took the photo Joel
initially told Tommy to keep it which he
did before Ellie stole it from them
minus the short introduction we haven't
really talked about Sarah much and
that's for good reason the game really
pushes her aside as that's what Joel is
trying to do he wants to forget about
his past as much as he can Joel lost his
daughter and his old life in one day and
seeing a picture of Sarah likely
reminded him of that day you would think
that at the very least he should have
something to remind him of Sarah and not
taking the photo would be very out of
character for him but not only does he
still have the watch that she gave him
20 years ago but if a picture causes
more pain than pleasure maybe it's best
not to keep it even if it is the last
remaining thing you have of a loved one
to get to the hospital the two will have
to take a detour into a tunnel which
just happens to be flooded one of the
bosses they used as a bridge ends up
getting caught in the waves and throws
the two Downstream Joel saves Ellie but
she needs CPR if she's going to make it
but that's when two guards come by and
ask him to put his hands up I love the
small detail of Joel not only not
listening to them but not even
acknowledging them as his full attention
is on Ellie doing this though means Joel
doesn't see the gun coming straight for
his head which knocks him out thankfully
these individuals were not Bandits but
rather fireflies as he wakes up next to
Marlene the guards just had no idea who
they were and that they were coming
which is why they attacked him to add
more good news to the pot not only is
Ellie okay but they're getting her ready
for the procedure until we discover that
it's a surgery a brain surgery according
to Marlene the reason Ellie is immune is
that the cordyceps attached to her brain
has mutated as they can extract it then
they can reverse engineer it and make a
vaccine but since it's attached to her
brain that means there also removing a
chunk of her brain in order to get it
meaning there is a 100 guarantee Ellie
will not survive the procedure Joel
refuses to accept this decision and
demands that he gets to see her Marlene
refuses as she knows that Joe will try
to take her so he has her guards escort
him out Joel manages to overpower the
guard and get info on her location now
we then have to battle through dozens of
armed men using anything weekends that
we can save Ellie before they do the
procedure even though there isn't a
timer during this Mission it felt as if
there was I was playing more
aggressively than normal and would rush
in to encounter sataka get to Ellie
faster Joel then meets with the doctors
and it's all in the player to advance
forward no cutscenes or QuickTime events
you pull the trigger when you want did I
go a bit overboard with the shotgun
probably but it got the job done which
is all that matters Joel then takes
Ellie out of the hospital kills Marlene
and heads off to Jackson Joel is
incredibly smart and he knows that
Marlene would just come for him later
which is why he's tying up as many loose
ends as he can Ellie will then wake up
in the car and ask what happened see
from her point of view she fell off the
bus in the tunnel and then awoke in a
car but she knows something happens that
she's in a hospital gown Joel then has
to lie to her and says that there were
other immune people that they found but
none of their tests worked so making a
cure would be impossible honestly from
the moment I killed the doctor to the
credits I was just speechless so much
happened in just a few minutes and I
don't even know what to say and it also
didn't help that numerous things I
thought would happen never came true
never in my wildest dreams that I think
Joel was going to murder Marlene and
then just straight up lie to Ellie about
the whole thing but I quickly started
realizing why lying to her was the right
choice because as the two walk back to
Jackson Ellie talks about the day she
got bit and says that it was with her
friend Riley when it happened the two
planned on waiting an output as we know
Ellie's immune so her day never came
Ellie has been really suffering with
some severe your survivor's Guild since
before the events of the game and it's
only gotten worse as it went done she
had her friend who will learn about in
just a moment but then there was also
Tess in Sam all these people became
infected and died yet she can't just
like anyone that suffers from this you
start to question why you were chosen
why me why was I the one to deserve life
these questions can be so strong that
some never crawl out from under their
weight and just wish that they died
alongside those that did the reason
she's bringing this up to Joel is
because she wants to know if what Joel
said about the fireflies was true Ellie
has been waiting for her turn to die
technically she should have died a long
time ago but she was chosen not to and
she's still trying to figure out why the
fireflies gave her the opportunity of a
lifetime she realized that she was
destined to live because she'd be the
Cure that prevents more people from
dying but as we know Joel took that
choice and opportunity away from her now
to be fair Ellie had no idea she was
going to die from her point of view she
fell off the bus and then awoke in the
car she had no idea that we visited the
fireflies stopped the surgery or even
knew that it was a surgery to begin with
so her knowing that info may have
persuaded not go through with it but
this is something we'll have to revisit
when we talk about part two so there's
no point discussing it now
circling back to Joel I think most of us
can agree that what Joel did was selfish
but if we were in his position we would
have done the same once I heard Ellie
was going to die I immediately tried
figuring out what we could have done to
stop that from happening the one thought
that did cross my mind during this was
how viable a vaccine would have even
been but it seems like I wasn't the only
one as many people for years have been
discussing the possibility of this
happening people have also gone a step
further and considered what would have
happened if they did succeed as some
claim that the fireflies would have just
sold it to people instead of just giving
it away so they could profit and others
have said that a war would have started
once news hit that a vaccine was being
made while I'm all for a theory and
speculation I think the weight of the
ending is lost if the vaccine couldn't
have been made having the fireflies fail
would make Joel's Choice pointless the
game portrays this Choice as a selfish
and incorrect one in an RPG this would
have been the bad ending and having the
vaccine not be successful means he would
have prevented Ellie from dying for no
reason thus being the good guy but Joel
is not and never has been the good guy
he's ruthless pragmatic and cares a
little about anyone but himself and
those he trusts he's not supposed to be
seen as a good person which is why I
think the ending would make more sense
if the surgery was guaranteed to succeed
regardless Ellie and Joel arriving in
Jackson means we've come to the end of
the game and already the series is off
to a great start first impressions are
incredibly important especially when it
comes to games and you couldn't have
asked for a better start I absolutely
loved this game and my feelings down it
still remained positive to this day
however we do have to talk about the DLC
I don't think Left Behind is a bad DLC
it's just sort of there I guess the DLC
covers the two most important parts of
Ellie's life the time she was bit and
discovered that she was immune and then
during the winter when Joel was injured
the premise so far is quite good and I
was interested to see where the DLC
would go but I finished it feeling like
I got played as it felt like a
cliffhanger type ending which is ironic
given that this is supposed to add
context to the scenes that were never
showcased similar to that winter chapter
we'll be going back and forth between
past and present Ellie throughout the
DLC to make it more digestible we'll
just talk about each section separately
in the past we get a chance to see how
Ellie and her friend Riley got bit and
it starts with the two meeting in
Ellie's room this is quite problematic
as Riley is a firefly and at least
sleeping at a boarding school hosted by
the military with the intention of
creating soldiers to fight the fireflies
ignoring the fact that Marlene is
totally comfortable with employing child
Soldiers the rest of the adventure
showcases how well established their
relationship is the two end up going to
an abandoned mall and just do kid stuff
they goof around in an arcade take
pictures in a photo booth and just
overall have a good time however the
infected have taken notice of their
Antics and want to join in on the
festivities sadly cordyceps isn't
allowed at this party so the two gotta
bounce the two girls are capable of
handling themselves but there is quite a
few infected chasing them and it's only
after taking down a few stragglers that
the two realize they've been bit their
lifespan has now been permanently
shortened and the two are debating on
what to do they decide to just wait it
out and be together in their final
moments but then the DLC just ends this
is what I meant about it feeling like a
cliffhanger the DLC is supposed to show
us how Ellie got bit but we never see
the most important part how she
discovered that she was immune there's
no scene showing Riley turn and having
Ellie kill her assuming she even did and
there's no follow-up showing Ellie
realized that it's been long enough and
nothing's happened it's just strange
that we spend so much time on this
relationship and never saw it to the end
having said that the relationship
between these two is great and shown
perfectly Riley was Ellie's best friend
in being able to see their relationship
was great but I do wish we got to see
the rest the present day plot isn't any
better in fact it's probably worse since
nothing of note actually happens Ellie
literally puts Joel in an abandoned
store finds a medkit stitches him up and
that's all this is the one part of the
campaign where Ellie has to do things
alone yet all she does is grab a med kit
they could have shown her hunting like
we saw at the beginning of that chapter
or even how she managed to find the
cabin and careful Joel just like the
other section it felt like the DLC
stopped right when it was getting good
the point was to show how Ellie got bit
but I think they took that too literally
as it only shows how she got bit and
then ends despite the fact that what
happens after the bite is more important
the part with Joel was honestly just
unnecessary and didn't need to be shown
at all what's worse is that this was
sold for 15
thankfully the remaster version came
with this for free as if it didn't I
would have easily recommend that you
don't buy it like I said at the top it's
not terrible it's not great either but
it's not the worst thing in the world
the combat was fun and seeing the
relationship between Ellie and Riley was
great but it also doesn't show more of
the important parts of these moments so
it just becomes extra content it's not a
bad nor is it a good DLC just exists and
I don't think that's what it should be
rated as it needed to be good not just
for that price but because it showed us
that it would explore these deeply
personal moments in Ellie's life but
they didn't deliver on it regardless of
my thoughts on the DLC as a whole
package The Last of Us Part One is an
exceptional game and has stunning
visuals balanced and engaging gameplay a
consistent Pace from beginning to end
and a gripping narrative that tells the
story of a man and his daughter quality
like this does not come by often and
you'll be doing yourself a disservice by
not playing it I truly without any
hyperbole love this game and thankfully
I'm not the only one who thinks that the
game is considered a must play on
Metacritic with a 95 rating and was
ranked the second most popular PS3 game
of its year just behind GTA 5. at a time
when people were questioning the
validity of gaming as an art form The
Last of Us arrived on scene improved
those doubters wrong seeing Ellie and
Joel's relationship change over the
course of the game made me care for
these characters in a way I haven't felt
before being able to walk talk and
interact with both Ellie and Joel gave
me the opportunity to see how this
unlikely pair became Partners in the
beginning but by the end would do
anything for each other even if it meant
Doom in the world it's a game that Ai
and many others enjoyed and will
remember for the years to come and due
to his popularity and critical reception
a sequel was inevitable
and seven years later the people got
their sequel in the form of The Last of
Us Part Two but its reception was less
than ideal there are those that say it's
the worst game ever made and that
naughty dog should be embarrassed about
the product they created others say it's
amazing and just as good as part one
regardless of your opinion on the game
you can see how drastically things have
changed just about everyone that played
part one was in agreeance this is an
incredible game for part two though
you'll get a different opinion every
time that's how divided the community is
on this game and as for me I think the
game is pretty damn good I don't
consider it to be better than part one
but I also don't think it's nearly as
bad as people are making it out to be
understand how bold that is to say but
genuinely I do think part 2 is a great
game that tells a very compelling
narrative about grief the reason I came
to that conclusion was because of the
game's second half which is ironic given
that many people think the game is bad
because of its second half we'll get to
all that in due time but I do hope one
thing we can agree on is that the
prologue starts off really damn well
part two starts five years after the
events of part one and it shows Joel
cleaning his guitar while explaining to
Tommy what happened at the hospital this
was mainly for returning players who
needed a refresher but I liked how
naturally it was placed into the story
Tommy is of course hearing all this for
the first time and while he's shocked to
hear what his brother had done he
understands why and says that he would
have done the same while the remake of
part 1 is the graphically Superior
version there is one benefit that the
remaster has over the Remake and that's
being able to see the leap in graphical
Hardware in real time one of my favorite
Parts about playing through a series for
a video especially one that's been going
on for a long time is seeing it evolve
over the years as technology gets better
seeing Kratos go from his original
appearance to his newest look 17 years
later in Ragnarok is amazing to look
back on and I feel the same way here
it's only been seven years since the
first game but Joel has undergone some
drastic visual changes and by playing
the Remake you would be robbing yourself
of this moment while this scene as
mentioned before serves as a recap for
the player more than anything the game
really emphasizes this moth on the
guitar by having it be the first thing
the player sees Neil druckman talks
about the a moth in an interview and
says that the moth symbolizes Joel but
also compulsion this guitar Jewel uses
will eventually be used by Ellie and
this moth is also a design she had
tattooed on her so she could cover up
the bite mark it's basically a constant
reminder that Joel is always with her
which will be very important going
forward furthermore malts are also
attracted to light by Nature almost as
if it's some kind of compulsion like
they need to find the light this is core
to the game's story as it's centered
around revenge and what Revenge does to
a person its inclusion in the game is
subtle but I liked how heavy the themes
and ideas are that surround the image
once Joel and Tommy finished talking the
two then head back to Jackson the same
town from part one get your play time in
with Joe while you can as this will be
the only time we actually play as him in
the game that's because our actual main
protagonist is Ellie this was a very
obvious decision as The Last of Us is
really about Ellie's story Joel does
play a massive role in shaping the world
as we know it and that event will
eventually come back around and
influence the entire plot of this game
but it felt like his story was finished
in part one Joel ended up getting what
he wanted he was able to keep belly safe
and give her a new life here in Jackson
there isn't anything he could have done
for the story that would make sense
without feeling like he was overstaying
his welcome which is why giving LED
protagonist's role was the most logical
Choice the game then switches over to a
scene of Joel and Ellie together it's
unclear how long it's been since part
one at this point but it doesn't seem
very long since Ellie is still rather
young the two talk for a bit and the
vibe is awkward it seems like the talk
they had at the end of part 1 is still
on each other's minds Joel attempts to
break the ice by playing a song for her
this like many things in part 2 are
callbacks to the previous game when
entering the university Joel tells Ellie
that he wanted to be a singer at one
point Ellie then begs him to sing but he
declines what seems like she got her
wish after all as Joel does just that to
add to the callbacks not only did he
mention that he was going to teach her
how to play which is something he said
in part one but Sam's toy the one Ellie
gave back to him is in her room on a
shelf which just goes to show how much
those two impacted her in both a good
way as they were nice people but also in
a bad way as it's still a constant
reminder that they died and she hasn't
we then fast forward four years later
and we get to see the real present-day
Ellie throughout the next couple of
minutes we'll learn that Jesse here and
his girlfriend Dina broke up but then
Dina went and kissed Ellie the night
before we also learned that this kiss
caused one of the residents to call
Ellie a slur this is one of the few
things that bothered me about part two
some of the game has this tell don't
show method of Storytelling which is
pretty ass backwards even worse the game
does actually show us this incident but
not until 20 hours later and by then I
don't really care I do like what the
flashback shows because it will become
very important later but I still think
naughty dog probably could have just
shown us the contents now and then
reference it later rather than telling
us now and then showing us later back to
the present though the plan for the day
is to go out on patrol Jesse will take
Tommy and Joel's post and Ellie and Dina
will do their route this will allow us
to get some one-on-one time with Dina to
see what he's really about before that
can happen though we're taken to a cabin
filled with people
the main two that we see are a guy and a
girl named Abby and Owen there are a ton
more people with them but for now these
are the main two Abby and Owen are also
on patrol but for a very different
reason they find a hillside that gives
them a good look at the town we just
came from apparently this group is
looking for someone in that town and
they don't seem to be nice people as
Abby suggests that they find one of the
outgoing patrols and interrogate them
meaning this group ain't here for some
chat and trade even with their group
though they aren't strong enough to take
on Jackson so Abby suggests the previous
plan of taking one of the patrols Owen
disagrees saying that it's too risky and
goes back to the cabin from here we'll
be switching back and forth between
these two until they meet so let me just
summarize all of them one at a time as
Ellie we end up traveling to some of the
outposts and also end up taking a break
with Dino so we can wait out the storm
this causes Dina and Ellie to talk about
their kiss last night but Ellie is
hesitant to give her thoughts on the
matter one of the game's Collectibles
are journal entries these unlike the
other Collectibles allow us to learn
more about Ellie and see what kind of
mindset she's in at the moment Ellie has
a paragraph in her journal that says
don't end the Friendship she clearly
likes Dina but she doesn't want it to
affect their relationship thankfully
Dina feels the same way about her and
the two share a kiss and even more
during their break the scene overall is
quite adorable as the two definitely
seem to care about one another on a very
deep level this is also the first time
we get to see one of Ellie's
relationships in game and it gets you
interested enough to see where it goes
from here there was Riley back in the
DLC who Ellie cared deeply for and then
apparently another girl named Kat who is
the one that gave Ellie the tattoo there
wasn't enough if any time to see those
relationships in action that's why
establishing this at the beginning
allows the rest of the story to use it
to its Advantage eventually they'll be
interrupted by Jesse who says that Joel
and Tommy didn't show up and it's been
over an hour the reason they didn't is
because they're currently lost in the
snowstorm Abby also happens to be lost
too but thankfully Tommy and Joel happen
to show up and save her the three then
get to a safe spot and discuss where to
go next Abby says she has a cabin of
friends not far from here they all agree
to go there once they have the
opportunity to and they introduce
themselves while I've always preferred a
consistent art style over realistic
graphics one thing it has an advantage
in is subtle movements just from the
facial capture alone you can tell
hearing Joel's name did set something
off within her brain and it's hard to
assume that Joel is the person she's
looking for now one common complaint
levied at this scene is that it's out of
character for Tommy to give out names
like this and I definitely agree while I
could forgive Tommy for the slip up
because he doesn't have the survivalist
mentality that Joel Has Not only was
Tommy a former Firefly for many years
but he just heard the story that Joel
told him it's safe to assume that people
would want Joel dead for doing this and
giving away his name was idiotic the
counter argument to this though is that
the two brothers have been spending a
lot of time in Jackson living a normal
life so they may have just let their
guard down and learned to be more
trustworthy than before whatever the
reason may be though revealing their
names was the worst mistake Tommy could
have ever made I look like you heard of
us or something
because they have
[Music]
Laura all clear he's out put him against
the wall zombie
ah
put it down get off me get our hands get
the [__] off me
[__] okay
[Music]
you're gonna [__] die
Jewel get up draw [__] get up
please stop
please
Joel please get up
[Applause]
Joel is officially dead this isn't one
of those things where he's barely alive
and is able to be taken to a hospital or
somehow gets a second wind through the
power of friendship Joel is well and
truly dead and it's only been two hours
since we started playing now at the
moment we don't know who these people
are and why they did this we could
assume that they're fireflies which is
what I assumed too and I was half right
but we'll talk about the real motivation
behind this later still though what a
shocking scene it's very realistic
portrayal of death not everyone gets to
go out in the blaze of glory sometimes
they die like a coward beaten to death
with a golf club while they're too weak
to move it's brutal and not only shows
how much hatred Abby had for Joel but
likely how much the player now has for
Abby she didn't even give the man a
chance to defend himself Joel does not
deserve to go out like that after
everything he's been through but death
and fate are a cruel mistress similar to
Sarah's death this too was spoiled for
me but honestly it was quite hard to
avoid since everyone was talking about
this even before the game launched I
specifically remember gameplay was
leaked prior to its release and everyone
took to Twitter and other platforms to
inform knows of what happened I was
sadly one of those people that had the
scene ruined for them but at the time it
didn't bother me since I had no
intentions of playing the series kinda
kicking myself for that now but just
like Sarah scene I hadn't heard the
scene in full before and it's still just
as gut-wrenching as it's supposed to be
Joel was an incredibly likable character
he was the protagonist of the last games
and we built a deep connection with him
same as Ellie but now both of us have to
say goodbye to him this event though is
what kicks off the real start of the
story and the plan is simple
kill Abby honestly I don't think anyone
playing this game needed any kind of
convincing once Ellie said she wanted to
find her I was in Ellie like myself
cares about Joel and there's no way
we're letting some girl in her gang get
away with killing them and Cold Blood
like that but we don't even know where
to begin thankfully Tommy noticed that
they had the words Washington Liberation
Front on their jackets which means that
they're likely from Seattle with all
that laid out Ellie along with Dina is
then all set to go to Seattle and take
the fight to Abby and Tommy while
originally saying he wants to talk to
Maria first ends up actually leaving
before Ellie does so all of them make
the Trek across the state
as an opening though it's pretty well
done apologies if the last few minutes
were filled with more summarization than
you're used to but you could see why it
was necessary to speed through the story
a bit there also wasn't a whole lot to
critique here in this section since not
much has really happened we've only just
been introduced to the new cast and
anything that's happened in the past few
minutes was done so that it could
influence the rest of the story
nonetheless it was still a great start
some may be disappointed that they
killed off Joel this early and yeah it
doesn't feel great but it does at least
get your attention now all the game has
to do though is to take this setup and
run with it
Abby being out of the picture allows the
game to focus more on Ellie which is
where the game really starts to open up
in regards to its gameplay part 2's
gameplay is very similar to that of part
1. if you liked the previous game for
its survival style gameplay then you'll
likely have no complaints when playing
part 2. there are small additions of
course but they're minor enough that
they don't change the flow of gameplay
if anything they enhance it one of which
is where enemies talk to each other
during combat and have actual names it's
an attempt to characterize these people
you're killing and really Hammer home
how much destruction you're doing the
original game had stuff like this too
like when enemies would announce that
you have no ammo if you try to shoot an
empty magazine but part 2 takes this to
another level as for the complaints I
really only have one and that's that
Ellie likes to announce when all the
enemies are dead she'll say something
like okay I think that's all of them or
something along those lines at the end
of every encounter okay why they did
this but I feel like it removes the
feeling of suspense that part 1 kept her
on its run time for example a little bit
later Ellie will run into a group of
stalkers but this time they actually
stalk the player they'll hide behind
these balls and jump you if you don't
see them it's a terrifying encounter but
once they're dead Ellie says that the
coast is clear knowing that the area is
clear of hostels I sprinted throughout
the area picking up any loose items I
didn't find since I was so focused on
killing had that not been included I
would have just left as I was already at
the exit but since Ellie said that they
were all dead I ran around without a
care in the world it just kills the
suspense of not knowing whether or not
every enemy in the area is truly dead
other than that though the gameplay was
just as great as the original and if you
play The Last of Us for the gameplay
alone you won't be disappointed the next
few minutes are a mix of gameplay and
puzzle solving just like the previous
games but there are a few moments where
the game focuses on our two lovebirds I
must say though I think part two really
drops the ball on the side characters
Jesse and Dina are likable enough but
they're never really given an
opportunity to express themselves in any
way one note would be a perfect way to
describe them because in this game it's
not about what makes them interesting
but what their role is to the story
there isn't enough info given to us
about Dina to make her interesting but
her role is Ellie's girlfriend her role
is important but everything about her
isn't which is a real shame I know the
focus of this game at least for now was
on Ellie but I do wish more time was
spent with the others I want to see what
Ellie sees in Dina and why she's so
special to her as for that particular
moment I mentioned earlier Ellie found a
guitar and decides to play a tune for
Dina the scene just like the one earlier
in the weed Den are adorable and I wish
I got to see more of it throughout the
game once again I know the focal point
of the story is Ellie but focusing so
much on her comes at the cost of the
other characters that surround her once
Ellie is done singing she and Dina will
eventually make it to one of the wlf
outposts and find some of Tommy's
handiwork
this is very similar to Joel's style of
interrogation which was that scene
during the winter seems like Tommy made
the guy write down some coordinates in
his own blood which is pretty gruesome
the two will then follow the trail
before being blown up by a landmine
Elise then knocked out before waking up
next to Jordan Jordan is the guy from
earlier who was slashed in the face
instead of killing her he wants to keep
Ali alive though so that he can get some
more information on who else she's
traveling with but the guy next to him
Mike argues with Jordan saying that
Isaac leader of the wlf has a new
mandate kill all trespassers their
argument gives Dina enough time to come
by and kill Mike before Jordan shoots
the glass causing her to fall Jordan
then for some odd reason decides to
choke Dean out which gives Ellie enough
time to escape and kill Jordan overall
the scene is as intense as it's intended
to be but I'm still puzzled as to why
Jordan didn't just kill Dina it's hard
to know what Jordan wanted with Dina
specifically as he could have just
wanted her as another Hostage to
interrogate for information but it's
also possible that he just wanted to
kill her assuming he really did just
want to kill her it's definitely very
odd he didn't just finish her off with
the gun he was already using on her her
things like this can be very tricky in
stories as you want to add tension and
suspense to engage the viewer but
sometimes the action that causes that
suspense like choking someone instead of
shooting them doesn't make any sense in
the context of the situation Jordan
dying though allows Ellie to find their
next Target Leah Jordan's girlfriend the
reason we know where Leah is located is
because on Jordan's corpse was a letter
from her that says that she'll be
stationed at the TV station for a bit
longer than usual since there are scars
in the area scars are what the wlf call
the Seraph fights another group within
the world of The Last of Us speaking of
the groups in this game I think part two
handled them quite well I was a bit
disappointed in the fireflies from the
last game and I guess I wasn't the only
one who thought about this as both
factions now play much larger roles in
this game we'll be meeting people from
each group quite a bit and majority of
the enemies placed through all the
levels that aren't infected are wlf or
seraphite members which was a smart
decision as it not only shows how much
territory these groups have but it's a
nice attempt of fleshing out the World
by adding more factions the fireflies in
the first game were a fairly interesting
group but since the game focused heavily
on Ellie and Joel not much screen time
was given to them outside of a few key
moments in this game though each faction
is much more important to the story and
you won't be forgetting about them
anytime soon such as right now as once
the two make it to the TV station they
find Leah but they were too late as the
seraphites got there first we get a few
teases of this air fights throughout the
previous gameplay sections that lead us
to the station and we consider a very
ruthless group of people they hang their
victims right before they disembowel
them they also mark their territories
with these victims as well as paint
their logo in blood we still have yet to
see an actual seraphite but we have seen
their handiwork and it is quite the
sight Leah being dead though means that
our leads have dried up but Leah had a
lot of stuff in her duffel bag that
could be helpful to their investigation
but it's also getting late so do need to
focus on finding a safe place to rest
first before they do that though Dina
and Ellie have a interesting
conversation
[Music]
yeah
she didn't hurt Joel it would have been
pretty [__] up to make her talk
traveled hundreds of miles to torture
him I don't care whether she held the
club or not
around this time Ellie ends up falling
and breaking her gas mask Dina is
naturally worried for Ellie's safety
until she tells her that she's immune
obviously this comes as quite the shock
to her but the game strangely pushes
this aside by revealing something even
Wilder and it's that Dina might be
pregnant and that Jesse is the father
while it is rather strange that the game
completely ignores how pivotal this
moment is as she hasn't revealed this to
anyone outside of Tommy and Joel I do
like the contents of the reveal Dina
being pregnant will be important as Mel
one of Abby's friends is also pregnant
and the game is going to use both of
these girls and their friends as
parallels in order to convey the point
it's trying to make it's also during
this time that we introduced to one of
the two new infected in part 2 the
shambler they are similar in design to a
bloater with the main difference being
that they release corrosive gas from
their body which melts the skin of
anyone nearby from what it can gather it
seems like once an infected becomes a
bloater it has a chance to mutate into a
shambler Instead This may be due to
Seattle's weather as it is very rainy
and Neil druckman is quoted in saying
that he wanted the environment and
weather to have a role in the infection
process the two then make it to an
abandoned theater they deem suitable to
live in which gives them enough time to
discuss the elephant in the room Dina
being pregnant is a problem as Ellie
doesn't want to put another being in
danger but she also wants to kill Abby
this causes a rift in their relationship
as Ellie calls her a burden now that
she's done this Ellie decides to let
things cool off between them though by
letting Dina rest while she Scopes out
the theater while doing so she ends up
finding a guitar and relaxes by playing
some music she ends up playing the song
Future Days by Pearl Jam which while
cool enough on its own is the same song
Joel sang for her in the prologue I find
the lyrics of the song rather
interesting in hindsight as the first
two lines read if I were to ever lose
you I would surely lose myself this line
seems to relate to both Ellie and Joel
if Joel were to lose Ellie he would
surely have lost himself which is why he
saves Ellie at the end of part 1 and if
Ellie loses Joel then she would lose
herself too and while it's on apparent
now I can assure you she will start to
lose that old side of herself throughout
the course of the game the scene then
cuts to Black before going to another
flashback this time three years ago as
we see Ellie and Joel on a walk together
this is the first time we've been able
to see joelson his death and these
flashbacks do provide a heartwarming
feeling if you have made it this far in
the game or even finished part 1 I find
it hard to believe that you don't like
Joel so seeing him happy and Alive with
Ellie is a great feeling the reason the
two are here is because Joel has a
surprise for Ellie and that's that
they're going to be exploring an
abandoned Museum not only are there
dinosaurs to explore but on the top
floor there is a space exhibit which if
you remember from part 1 Ellie said one
of her dreams was to be an astronaut
Joel also remembers this as he managed
to find an old tape of an official
launch for Ellie to listen to while she
sits in one of the pods it's incredibly
adorable and I must say that it's
extremely impressive that Naughty Dog
managed to keep the emotions of the
player and the player character
consistent no matter which part of the
duo we end up playing as in part one we
played his Joel and we grew to love
Ellie alongside him we were both happy
when we found her at the end of the
winter chapter and we were both willing
to lay our lives down if it meant
getting Ellie out of that hospital but
in part 2 we play as Ellie and not only
felt that pain and anger she felt when
Joel died but also this current feeling
of Happiness as we get to spend more
time with Joel again also when I know
I'm getting a bit ahead of myself here
but there's another flashback later that
reinforces this idea as the two get into
a few combat encounters together and it
felt like I was playing part 1 again but
from Ellie's perspective it felt great
to kill infected in Bandits alongside
Ellie in part 1 and it feels nostalgic
to do it again here in part two it's
genuinely some impressive work a naughty
dog really deserves some credit for how
well they pulled this off
once you're done looking through the
exhibit and chatting with Joel you can
continue through to another section of
the museum the two will have to split up
to do so but once they meet up they'll
see a firefly logo with the words of
liars underneath it judging from Ellie's
reaction you can get the sense that she
doesn't fully believe what Joel told her
at the end of part 1 and is something
that will come up again a bit later
this scene brings us to the end of the
flashback and the end of day one and
honestly it's been quite underwhelming
there's a major contributor to this that
I'll talk about a bit later but not much
has happened so far and it's been
roughly five hours since we started her
campaign there was a few nice moments
with Dina like with the guitar and when
the two explore synagogue but outside of
that Dina and Ellie don't talk too much
unless it has to do with the mission or
something that's in front of them and
the game doesn't even give them the
opportunity to interact with anything
either since it's just back-to-back
gameplay thankfully though day two is a
bit better
Ellie and Dina haven't talked much since
last night but it seems like both of
them are okay and not mad at one another
Dina also takes it upon herself to
listen in on the radio chatter coming in
from the wlf since she's pregnant and
throwing up all the time she can't be
out in the field like Ellie is so she's
trying to help out the best she can and
not feel like a burden according to Dina
someone on the Comm said there was a
lone male trespasser that was spotted
near site 14 which he says might be
located near a place called Hillcrest
the two assume that this trespasser is
Tommy until Ellie goes by herself to
investigate and learns that it's
actually Jesse Jesse had heard that
Tommy Dina and Ellie went off to find
Abby and obviously he wasn't going to
lie down and let them handle it which is
why he made the solo track here given
that it's only been a couple days since
we arrived in Seattle we can assume that
Jesse likely left the same day as we did
and has been trying to find us ever
since Jesse then has the bright idea to
steal one of the W Wolf's cars and drive
away but the two end up getting caught
and have to now outrun more wlf soldiers
and dozens of infected it's a pretty
standard chase scene but encounters like
this always get the blood pumping no
matter the context it also characterizes
Jesse a bit as we can deduce from the
scene that he tends to not think things
through all the time taking one of their
cars was risky enough especially since
we almost bit it just trying to get the
car started in the explosions we saw
When approaching the area were likely
him too so Jesse's kind of a reckless
person that being said though he is
still serious when he needs to be which
will see a bit more of in day three but
for now Jesse and Ellie go back to the
theater and regroup with Dina Ellie
doesn't plan to stay long as Dina got a
tip that Nora one of Abby's friends is
stationed at the nearby hospital the
journey to the hospital is pretty bog
standard in terms of gameplay until
Ellie runs into the Sarah fights
I absolutely love the introduction of
the seraphites it starts with Ellie
entering a large forested area but once
she gets in the grass you hear someone
whistle this will immediately put you on
high alert which is why it took the long
way around and crawled through the grass
before I got shot with an arrow the
group also communicates their whistling
which I found to be incredibly
fascinating basically certain whistles
mean certain things like searching
attacking Etc if each of the commands
are consistent though so you could in
theory learn the whistles if you wanted
to by far one of their most annoying
ones is their call and response whistle
where one person calls and the others
whistle in response the thing is though
is that if no one responds then they
know something happened and then the
patrol routes change making it harder to
kill them but this is just one of the
things that sets the Seraph bites apart
from other groups they're a very typical
religious cult that uses older
technology like bows and arrows as
opposed to guns as they deem it's you
sinful although some members mainly
soldiers are exempt from this rule given
that they're still at war with the wlf
we also know what they do to the people
they kill as we saw their creations at
the TV station it's unclear if they
always take hostages or only the ones
that they can spare but it does seem
like this hanging and torturing is a
part of their killing process the group
deems this necessary as they believe
that they are cleansing the world of sin
likely by releasing it from their guts
as they hang which is why they
disembowel their victims the group also
lives on a remote island off the coast
called haven where they all live in Wood
huts and long houses the concept of a
religious cult may not be anything
original compared to other media but
within the last of us it most certainly
is while the wlfr cool faction they
don't have enough unique things about
them that set them apart from other
groups like The fireflies they're just
your standard everyday militia the
seraphites though are incredibly unique
and were easily my favorite faction in
the game due to how different they are
from everyone in regards to both
gameplay and story once Ellie makes it
to the hospital she ends up
interrogating one of the guards for
information the girl fights back though
and Ellie has to kill her she ends up
saying that she was dumb when she stabs
her likely referring to herself since
she let the girl get a chance to strike
her Shane the girl had to die though
because if you look at what she was
doing she was in the middle of playing
Hotline Miami on her PS Vita Ellie then
makes it to the upper floors of the
hospital and ends up finding Nora Nora
though isn't willing to give up any info
on Abby plus she also taunts Ellie by
bringing up Joel you still hear his
screams
I hear them every night
yeah
yeah that little [__] got what he
deserved
[Music]
her last line is pretty ironic given
she's about to get what's coming to her
too as Ellie chases her throughout the
hospital but ends up getting cornered by
some wlf as the hole behind her goes
into a Spore infested room however since
Ellie's immune none of this bothers her
so she'll get to have some one-on-one
time with Laura and take as long as she
wants Ellie ends up using a lead pipe to
utterly beat Nora to death it's
definitely one of the most gruesome acts
of violence we've seen so far from her
since her fight with David now obviously
Ellie wasn't here to kill her she just
needed info on Abby sadly Nora won't
sell out her friend but she does mention
how Ellie can breed the spores Nora then
puts two and two together and realizes
that Ellie was that girl from the
hospital which means that Nora used to
be a firefly it's also safe to assume
that Nora Abby and her crew all work
together meaning they're all former
fireflies I say former because Nora says
that the fireflies are all gone they've
disbanded and aren't a group anymore at
least within Seattle and Utah it's
unclear if all the fireflies are fully
gone since they are a large group and we
did see some back in Boston during the
First games prologue that being said
though we now know why Abby and the crew
hunted down Joel they were former
fireflies and wanted Joel dead for what
he did back at the hospital in part one
but as I said that's only half the story
Ellie then comes back from the hospital
and she's a mess you can see it on her
face that she's not all there mentally
and she's shaking before she enters the
theater she did look quite pissed right
before the screen cut to black but not
nearly as bad as this that's because off
screen she continued to beat Nora into
submission which is how she managed to
make her talk it comes as quite the
shock that she was willing to go that
far but I do think showing that scene
would have gone a long way as to me the
framing of this scene implied that this
was the last strike that killed Nora not
just wounding her but maybe that's just
me regardless we do get to see a bit
more of Ellie's body later and she looks
pretty rough and the camera does an
excellent job of showing the player how
much this journey has taken a toll on
her both physically and mentally Dina of
course being the amazing girlfriend she
is Comforts Ellie in this moment and
lets her know that everything is going
to be okay Ellie's mind is all over the
place here she's conflicted on what to
do is unsure whether or not this journey
is even worth it and also what Dina
thinks among many other things it's
really just becoming too much for her
this is also what I meant when I said
earlier about the roles of the
characters being important not the
characters themselves as Dina is sort of
like Ellie's Rock notice how in day one
things were quite tame when it came to
killing but now that Ellie is alone and
no longer has Dina to keep her in check
she gets Reckless and bashes Nora
scullin with a pipe we can of course
relate this back to our older discussion
about Dina and Ellie talking about Leah
and if making her talk would have been
Justified at least sees nothing wrong
with torturing her she did travel all
the way just to kill Joel but Dina sees
her as innocent and she had nothing to
do with this Dina is Ellie's voice of
reason and by not having her by her side
it means Ellie gets incredibly angry and
takes things too far in all fairness
though you might find this strange and
likely agree with Ellie's actions here
they kill Joel they deserve it like I
said I want to revisit this later but
think about that are you on Dina side or
Ellie's as I said earlier day two was a
bit better than before we started seeing
more things take effect throughout the
story like Ellie's obsession with
killing Abby and how this rage has
driven her to kill others in vicious
ways and we also get introduced to Jesse
which means we get more opportunity to
see what his deal is
things so far have been set up quite
well so let's see how they finish it
with day three but before we can
continue the game gives us yet another
flashback in fact we actually got two on
this day one now and one earlier when we
came back with Jesse but I figured I
would cover them both now at the same
time as they focus on the same thing the
first one is another one of those
heartwarming moments where we get to
interact with Joel before he died but as
a bonus we get a chance to hunt some
Infected down with Tommy Tommy always
felt like he was put on the back burner
when it came to the series so being able
to see him do more than just defend
Jackson was great he sadly doesn't show
up much in Ellie's campaign but he does
have a great Cameo later that I really
liked once Ellie and Tommy finish
hunting infected the two go back to the
cabin where Joel is located you'll
notice when playing this section that
something feels off Ellie is not as
talkative and it seems like something is
bothering her that's why Tommy wanted
both her and Joel to go do some patrols
together so the two can have some time
to talk this is where that Nostalgia
came in as like I said I felt like I was
playing part one again but from Ellie's
perspective the two didn't do quite a
few firefights with a lot of infected
and once the two survived the assault
they they decide to pack it up and go
home before leaving though Ellie finds
two skeletons on the floor Joel mentions
a bit earlier in this Mission how a
couple ran away from Jackson at one
point and it seems like these two bodies
are that couple the two of them left a
note that talks about them wanting to
leave Jackson so they could help the
people outside the walls of the city
sadly this didn't last long as it took
out bit about an hour after leaving to
make things worse the two were teenagers
so they had their whole lives ahead of
them only for it to be snuffed out
instantly thanks to the cordyceps this
once again brings us back to Ellie's
Survivor Guild as they died from the
infection yet she's still alive thanks
to this discovery though the topic of
discussion is once again brought up
it's now really the time for this
we traveled
across the entire country to bring me to
the fireflies
I had so many questions for them
why did you pull me out of there while I
was still unconscious
because I let them ruin their tests
and when I saw that they were useless
how do you know they were useless maybe
if you you just would have given them
more time they could have figured
something out
there was
no cure
Ellie is clearly pissed off and even
though she drops the conversation you
could tell she's not satisfied which
takes us to her next flashback where we
see Ellie visit the same hospital where
it all went down so she can find some
answers for herself Ellie ends up
finding a recording that talks about how
they escaped and that their chances of a
vaccine are gone but not because the two
left but because Joel killed the only
doctor that could have made it happen
Joel then arrives on Horseback and Ellie
brings up the conversation again before
the final time
making a vaccine
would have killed you
so I stop them
oh my God
[Music]
oh
my God you [__] touch me
[Music]
I'll go back
but we're done
Ellie finally learns the truth about
what happened that night she has been
dealing with survivor's guilt since she
was bit five years ago and hearing that
she actually had the chance to die and
make her life mean something only for it
to be taken away tears her apart going
back to our earlier conversation at the
end of part 1 regarding whether or not
Ellie would have gone through with the
surgery if she knew she would have died
I think it's safe to assume that she
would have or else she would have
thanked Joel for saving her furthermore
this connects to the first conversation
we have with Jesse Regarding why Ellie
was mad at Joel for standing up for her
it's not that she was mad at Joel for
what he did to Seth but it's just that
he was mad at him in general and didn't
want him in her life as she finds it
incredibly hard to forgive him after
what he did I think my only gripe with
this scene is its placement this
happened in Universe two years ago
meaning This Ellie we've been playing as
the whole time knew about what happened
my first reaction to this scene wasn't
oh here we go now she knows it was wait
a minute so she's known the whole time
I've been playing as her I thought for
long stretches of time that Joel died
with that secret and I was wondering how
Ellie was going to learn of this herself
if she ever would then come to find out
she already knew well I like the
contents of the flashbacks themselves
their placements are just bizarre in all
honesty the whole thing as a concept is
bizarre I know that making all this
chronological would slow the pace of the
game down since it officially starts
once Joel dies but still its inclusion
is very strange to me with that though
we have come to day three and Jesse and
Ellie have a talk regarding Dina Jesse
learns that she's pregnant and says that
they need to go back to Jackson so she
can get the care she needs Ellie agrees
but is of course very reluctant to do so
since she came here to get revenge and
doesn't want to leave empty-handed
specially since we've already killed
some of her friends already furthermore
Ellie also doesn't want to leave Tommy
behind since he's still doing his thing
out there so the plan is to get Tommy
and then find a way back to Jackson to
do that though they plan to go to the
aquarium and hold out there until they
find his location on the way to the
aquarium Jesse brings up a few good
points he asks Ellie if she's okay with
leaving some of Abby's crew behind she
says that it's okay because Dina needs
to be back in Jackson Jesse then asks if
she thinks they'll come back to Jackson
they might want to get revenge for what
Ellie did but she responds by saying
that she only came here because of what
Abby did but Jesse claps back and says
that they only came to Jackson because
what Joel did it's a bit confusing but
Jesse is trying to tell not only Ellie
but the player that maybe this trip
isn't worth the trouble and that this
cycle of Revenge isn't going to go away
the trip to the aquarium is quite long
but thankfully the two find a boat which
will allow them to travel through the
flood but right before they entered the
mall the two heard some chatter about a
sniper who they assume is Tommy Jesse
wants to go save Tommy before he's
killed but Ellie wants to go to the
aquarium as Abby could be there you
start to see how this Revenge trip is
causing Ellie to distance herself away
from her friends she called Dina a
burden earlier and now refuses to help
Tommy and Jesse if it means going after
Abby once the two split up because they
couldn't find a compromise Ellie then
grabs the boat and makes it to the
aquarium but instead of finding Abby she
finds Owen and Mel Abby is not here
though and the two refuse to give up her
position both of them are worried that
she'll kill them anyway even if they did
but Ellie says they can survive if they
just do what she says just like the
brothers Ellie also uses their
interrogation tactic by having Mel point
to where she is on the map and then
having Owen confirm it this doesn't work
though as Owen attempts to disarm Ellie
and then gets promptly shot in the
stomach which is Then followed by Mel's
own death thanks to Ellie stabbing her
in the throat this is where the gore of
the game really started to hit Me part 2
can be pretty gruesome at times and
these deaths were really where it
started to set in as stated before part
2 was quite divisive amongst fans and a
major complaint I saw was that the game
was supposed to show you that violence
is bad yet never gives you a chance to
stop that violence while I agree to some
extent I also want to offer a counter
argument that you might want to consider
the game is trying to show you that the
violence and death Ellie is committing
are bad but it's only supposed to stop
at her this is a problem because games
are not only artificial but it's also an
interactive medium so our actions are
Ellie's actions but we're supposed to be
the player and spectator of this game
and that's tough to do when we play
through the whole thing ourselves part 2
is trying to show us that Ellie's
actions are terrible and unnecessary
even though we are the ones to actually
act out these actions we're still
supposed to be mad at Ellie for doing
this she is the one putting us in this
position in the first place as she's the
one that keeps going out to Surge for
Abby essentially she's holding the gun
for us and telling us to pull the
trigger this would connect to the game's
message as if we were able to spare
these people then the whole story is
lost at least journey is fueled by
hatred and revenge which is why her
violence is becoming more unhinged she
doesn't care what happens to Abby's
friends and these no-name soldiers not
only have orders to shoot trespass
passers which he is but they're also
preventing her from reaching her
objective if Ellie was able to spare
these people but the events of the game
still played out normally then it'd be
too drastic of a change to see her be a
pacifist one minute then bludgeonore the
next this journey is supposed to be one
of violence anger and hatred and we're
supposed to be disappointed in Ellie for
not only doing this but also putting us
in a situation where we have to do it
too the following reveal also reinforces
the point that we should be disappointed
in her for what she did as it's revealed
that Mel was pregnant this causes her to
have a panic attack now that she's come
to terms of what she just did thankfully
Tommy and Jesse show up just in time to
save her though oddly enough if you
listen closely it kind of sounds like
Joel is calling out to her instead of
Tommy
[Applause]
I wonder if it's her mind thinking it's
Joel because she wants him to come save
her like he did back during the winter
really goes to show how much he still
cares for him even after what he did
thanks to Owen though they're out of
leads not like that was the plan anyway
since they were just here to get Tommy
and then go back to Jackson it was only
during their argument with Jesse where
she decided to go find Abby on her own
back at the theater though Jesse Tommy
and Ellie talk about how to get back
while Dina sleeps the problem though is
that Ellie dropped her map and never
picked it back up at the aquarium as she
was still too deep in her panic attack
to notice
oh [__]
stand up hands in the air I shoot this
one too don't you do it Ellie get out of
here stand up now put your [__] dare
shut the [__] up
all right stop stop
once again this further confirms that
places of Glory do not exist in the
world of The Last of Us and Jesse was
not an exception before we can even come
to terms of what just happened we get
another flashback but this time from
Abby's perspective this takes place five
years ago and from this flashback we
learned why Abby killed Joel yes she is
a firefly but she has a personal stake
in this quest for Revenge because the
doctor Joel killed was her dad Jerry
Anderson was his name and Abby was his
daughter that's why she came to Jackson
said Joel could pay for murdering her
dad things are starting to make much
more sense now naturally this is around
the time we come back to the present and
see how things unfold right we're at the
final few minutes of the game and we're
ready to see how it ends wrong we have
just reached the halfway point of part
two as right after this Abby awakes from
a dream and the title card says Seattle
day one meaning we have to go through
these same three days again as Abby this
is why a lot of people were disappointed
with this game it is a lot to ask a
player to do probably the most I've ever
been asked in my life not only did Joel
die of an hour forced to play as his
killer and not for a short time might I
end which brings me to my least favorite
part about this game it's pacing part
two when it comes to its length and
Order of events is just bad the thing is
though is that there's no other way to
fix this that doesn't require rewriting
the whole thing chronological order
doesn't work as we've already discussed
but flip-flopping between both of them
each day won't work either and by
flip-flopping I mean that they employ
what they did during the winter chapter
in part 1 but for all of part two so we
would do Ellie's day one then Abby's day
one and then back and forth until they
meet at the theater the problem is that
the reason that was so successful in
part one was because it was short and
narratively it made sense the whole
chapter is no longer than an hour or two
so going back and forth like that won't
disrupt much of the gameplay plus Ellie
was a side character at least for the
purposes of gameplay as she had no
upgrade tree like Joel and most enemies
dropped ammos that you could keep
fighting unlike Joel where enemies
didn't drop anything at all sometimes
they did that so that the player didn't
have to get bogged down by the gameplay
during Ellie section since they already
have to manage ammo and supplies as Joel
doing that with Ellie and Abby makes no
sense since they have completely
different inventories weapons and
upgrades it would just disrupt the flow
of the gameplay if we switched off at
the end of each day more importantly
though it narratively doesn't make sense
either since we're gonna have to wait
the same amount of time to reach this
climax anyway the current way is just
teasing us first but that tension that
chapter provided is not present in this
game Ellie and Joel in that chapter were
minutes apart and felt like we were just
on our heels but we needed to go faster
if we had any chance of catching her
that doesn't work in part 2 as Abby and
Ellie never meet hell Abby has no idea
she's even being hunted by Ellie until
this moment the closest these two get is
the hospital and the aquarium where Abby
goes to the hospital to meet Nora and
then hours later Ellie comes by and
kills her after the aquarium Ellie comes
and kills melon Owen and then Abby
presumably arrives a few hours later
this isn't one of those cliches where
our two protagonists are just a block
away or Ellie's hiding from a group of
wlf members and then come to find out
Abby was in that group and they just
missed each other they are literally
miles apart for 90 of the game so this
method wouldn't work it would just make
the pacing even worse the only way to
fix this is to just simply reduce the
run time so far I've written about 13
pages on part two and assuming my math
is correct we've been roughly talking
about this part for 50 minutes but you
don't even know the half of it this so
far has been 12 hours of gameplay and we
have another 10 to go before we can get
back to the scene so much of this game
is Just back-to-back combat encounters
when I do these videos I usually have
the recordings on my second monitor so I
can go back and watch it while I write
multiple times I scrub through hours of
footage just to get to the next part
since all of it was gameplay for example
in this video we went from Jordan to Leo
right away but that was separated by an
hour and 30 minutes of gameplay during
my playthrough and then I had to wait
another hour but before we got to the
theater I summarized that section in
just a few minutes but it took over two
hours just to play as much as I love the
gameplay in this game I feel like some
of these long stretches of combat could
have been cut down a bit for further
context part 1 took about 12 hours for
me to beat which was about as long as
Ellie's campaign Alone part 2 is
basically double the length of part one
as always though there is a massive
caveat to all this as pacing is
extremely subjective game length is a
weird thing to discuss since there's no
definitive number because it's all based
on the feelings of the player and some
people have different tolerances for
this stuff I found Assassin's Creed
Valhalla to be way too damn long but I
played Elder ring for even longer and
found its length adequate the numbers
and feelings are never going to be
consistent which is why it needs to be
judged on its own and In My Eyes Part 2
felt like it was dragging on far too
long but if you disagree I'd love to
hear why as for the real elephant in the
room that of course being Abby's
campaign you'll already know that I
didn't mind this at all in fact I feel
like without it the game wouldn't be as
complete firstly ignoring whose campaign
it is I'm just glad we got something at
all because if the game was truly going
to end at this theater it would probably
be even worse than its reception is now
because realistically what have we done
so far story wise all Ellie has done is
kill four of Abby's friends and that's
it nothing has actually happened our
objective hasn't even been complete yet
since we haven't even met Abby until now
nothing was learned nothing was gained
and we didn't even get to hear much
about Dina and Jesse it would honestly
be a pretty pathetic game if it was just
Ellie's campaign but while some may
agree with that take they may also think
that Abby's campaign was not a good
substitute for it but I massively
disagree furthermore I heard many people
say that Abby's campaign was placed here
so that you could feel sympathy for her
and that the main theme of the game is a
poor attempt at saying revenge is bad
but I also have to disagree with that
personally I don't feel sympathy for
Abby at all I think if Ellie killed her
it would be totally justified the thing
is though is that it's not going to
solve anything Abby and Ellie are two
sides of the same coin two girls whose
fathers died by someone for some unknown
reason Abby's campaign is going to show
us how she got over the grief of losing
her dads that we the player can hope
that Ellie does the same if it worked
for Abby it has to work for her too
because ultimately that's what all of us
really want at the end of the day we
just want Ellie to feel better and to be
that happy kid we remember from part one
not the grief-stricken murderer of part
2. and nabi's campaign is going to show
how that's possible by giving us a
chance to see someone else go through
the same thing
Abby's first day in Seattle starts at
the wlf base with her being awoken by
Manny for context many was the one who
spit on Joel after Abby killed him we'll
also end up meeting Jordan Mel and Alice
all of whom we are familiar with except
for Alice who is the group's guard dog
she like the others is also dead because
right before Ellie met Owen and Mel at
the aquarium she felt the revenge in the
ceiling and had to put Alice down it is
definitely a strange feeling seeing all
these people happy just knowing that in
a couple days they'll all be dead as for
the base itself the wlf have settled
into a nearby stadium and they seem to
be doing well for themselves it's hard
to compare Jackson to the wlf base since
we don't get an opportunity to walk
around the town but it does seem like
the wlf have a lot more resources than
they do especially since Jackson was
mainly meant to be a town with civilians
where the wlf base has soldiers in it
this also isn't their only base as
Abby's job for the day is to run some
patrols and eventually make it to one of
their fobs joining her on this
Expedition will be Manny Alice and Mel
it's definitely strange that Mel is
coming along since she is very clearly
pregnant and but this is supposed to be
a routine Patrol so it should be safe
for her to come along as they aren't
expecting combat which means we're going
to be expecting combat the Seraph fights
Ambush the truck and we have to fend
them off before the chaos ensues though
Abby and Mel talk for a bit and you
start to get the sense that they aren't
on good terms and this is likely due to
Owen we'll cover the flashbacks that
show this info later but Abby and Owen
used to date before Owen moved on to Mel
but as we'll soon see their feelings
haven't wavered and this causes some
issues for this Trio that's why Mel
mentions Owen's name when they talk
about picking up more assignments since
Mel probably assumes that Abby's picking
up more shifts that she could be with
Owen during this conversation Mel also
asks Abby how she's been sleeping these
days despite the fact that she's finally
taken down her father's killer she said
that her sleeping is still as bad as
it's been before Abby doesn't seem to be
the only one who was affected by that
night as some of her friends are either
traumatized and or regret doing it in
the first place slowly but surely the
idea starts the trickle in that none of
them were too happy with what happened
that day Abby is the one that was
affected the least by this but that's
still just as concerning since this
actor was supposed to to heal her and
allow her to get closure yet nothing
happened after the group clears out the
serophytes they'll eventually reach the
base before they get some bad news
apparently their friend Danny died
recently even more worrying is that Owen
was with him and they haven't heard from
him since Manny and Abby then go and
find Isaac to see what's up but he's
currently busy torturing a seraphite
they have locked up at the base Isaac is
a ruthless leader and he seems to be
taking things a bit too far at points
but that's due to his history with the
seraphites the wlf have been at war with
the Sarah fights for quite some time the
wlf took over fedra the military and
were considered the biggest threat in
Seattle until the seraphites came in and
started encroaching on their land the
surfhites were led by a woman named the
prophet and her in the wlf exchange
blows on several occasions at one point
the truce was made with the hope that
they could stop the fighting but it was
eventually broken only a short time
after its Inception this led to dozens
of skirmishes and battles one of which
resulted in the wlf capturing the
prophet herself Isaac personally handed
her interrogation and after growing
weary about the current state of the war
opted to have her executed this threw
the call to do frenzy and resulted in
them taking over the land where she was
executed which is now known as martyr's
gate Isaac had hoped that killing their
leader would have stopped the war but
it's only made it worse which is why
he's currently planning a strategy for
the final battle which involves them
burning down Haven ending the war for
good as I said earlier the lore of these
factions runs deep and I'm so glad that
the factions of the world got more
attention this time around as it makes
them feel like genuine parts of the
world and not just names and a lore
document the seraphites are an
incredibly unique faction for the way
they communicate to even how they were
formed and the wlf while not anything
groundbreaking is at least expanded upon
which makes the war between these
factions feel important
this war that Isaac is planning is also
important though as Abby's going to be
on the front lines Abby is very well
known amongst the wlf she's considered
Isaac's best soldier and arguably the
best certified killer in the entire
faction she's killed hundreds if not
thousands of Sarah fights on her own and
has personally interrogated just as many
she's ruthless and efficient and I think
a lot of this is because of what
happened to her father in the past five
years since her father died Abby's
gained quite a bit of muscle mass so
it's safe to assume that this event
hardened her and killing seraphoids was
sort of a way for her to de-stress sadly
Isaac's plan is going to have some holes
in it thanks to Abby going AWOL in the
next few minutes this is because Isaac
tells her how Danny died which prompts
Abby to seek out in search for Owen
that's because it's learned that Owen
was the one who killed Dany it may seem
odd for Abby of all people to disobey
Isaac but I never got the idea that Abby
was actually loyal to him Abby and her
crew who Isaac calls the Salt Lake crew
were all former fireflies and Isaac took
them in out of the kindness of his heart
but the wlf are not their friends they
may respect these people but they don't
converse with them casually outside of
missions while they will will help the
wlf if the going gets tough they only
look out for each other and right now
one of their own might be in trouble
Abby is also quite positive that she
knows where Owen is and that's the
aquarium multiple flashbacks will
confirm this as Owen seems to be making
this place his home while on the way to
the aquarium Abby gets caught by some
Sarah fights and is knocked out she then
awakes next to a few other seraphites
while they drag her to their hanging
post Abby's about to be one of those
bodies we found at the TV station but to
save thanks to one of their members
finding someone called Yara shortly
after another person arrives named Lev
both Lev and Yara are former seraphites
who left the cult for an unknown reason
at least for now love then cause I'd be
down thanks to her helping them which
prevents her from dying the three aren't
out of the woods yet pun intended as
there are stalkers that roam this forest
and the trio has to go through waves of
infected before making it to safety I
will say though there is something
incredibly satisfying about watching
this hulking Beast of a woman curb stomp
infected into the ground like it's
nothing despite the fact that they are
serifieds Abby works with them anyway
this isn't wildly out of character for
her as like I said Abby seems to place
her loyalty in people she trusts and
Yara and Lev are not only being hunted
by the same people as Abby but they also
helped her full well knowing that she
was a wlf soldier I must say I'm also
quite surprised that the game didn't
attempt to shoehorn them in just yet as
once they make it to a safe spot Abby
helps Yara with her arm and then leaves
she had no intention of actually staying
with them but she figured his payment
for saving her she should at least make
sure they're safe usually some games
would come up with some unrealistic
reason for why they stick together since
the developers want them to be together
as soon as possible this could be quite
common in many RPGs that have multiple
companions as each one needs a reason to
join and sometimes that reason makes no
sense now obviously Naughty Dog isn't
that bold enough to just introduce two
new characters and then have them never
appear again so even though Abby leaves
them alone for now she will eventually
come back and meet them but I found her
reasoning for doing so to not be that
outlandish that reason in question comes
from a nightmare she has at the aquarium
when she arrives at said aquarium she'll
meet with Owen who is sitting in a boat
Abby will talk with Owen before asking
of what Isaac said is true Owen confirms
that he did indeed shoot Dany when Adam
Patrol both him and Dany were fighting
some seraphites one of whom was this
older man Owen hit him really hard on
the head but instead of the man reaching
for his gun he just sat there the man
was clearly tired of the war and didn't
want to fight anymore Owen says that
he's killed a lot of scars in his time
but this one really got to him which is
why he didn't kill him Danny was going
to finish him off for him which is why
Owen retaliated by putting a bullet in
his chest Abby clearly cares about Owen
and so she tries to come up with some
sort of plan to fix this but Owen
doesn't care he's just sick of all the
fighting in fact Owen wants to leave
Seattle and go to Santa Barbara
apparently he heard that the fireflies
were attempting to rebuild there and he
wants to go see if it's true Abby scoffs
at this not only calling him insane but
also saying that he needs to grow up
that's when Owen gets on her case about
her killing Joel saying how do I grow up
Abby do I go find the people that killed
my family and make them pay for what
they did this leads into a physical
altercation before things get even more
physical but in a more passionate way as
shocking as this is once again it's not
as wild as it seems as just like Ellie's
campaign we also get a couple flashbacks
during this day all of which revolve
around Owen the flashbacks do a pretty
good job of showing the characters
actions and emotions before this moment
which overall helps the scene make more
narrative sense for example you can tell
that Owen for years has always been
hesitant to place his loyalties in the
factions he's a part of and is also able
to recognize that they have all done
some bad things I just don't understand
how anybody willingly joins the scars
why not
because they're an insane cult that's
why
well in the cuese people would refer to
the fireflies of terrorists fanatics
we were naive
we weren't fanatical
we blew up checkpoints and assassinated
soldiers it's not the same I'm just
saying don't say [__] like that at the
stadium okay okay all right
you defended yourself
I can fix this I'll talk to Isaac I am
tired Abby
I don't want to fight over land that I
don't give a [__] about
furthermore the flashbacks also show how
deep their love is for each other as in
our first flashback which takes place
three years ago Owen and Abby are
currently exploring the aquarium but for
the first time the two end up sharing a
kiss at the end before Abby backs away
she cares about Owen but this thing with
Joel is driving a wedge between them as
it's all she can think about the same
thing happens in the next flashback
which is four months ago and roughly
right before they all leave to go to
Jackson Abby comes over to the aquarium
and we can see that Owen has added some
decorations and really made the place
his own Mel also seems to have taken
residence here which causes some
problems for these two at this point in
the timeline Abby and Mel are still not
on good terms thanks to Abby still
showing interest in Owen even after they
broke up the promise that they never
officially broke up Abby's Quest
revengeance created some distance
between the two but it's clear that the
feelings are still there both of them
clearly like each other but it's more
awkward now since Owen has moved on and
is also going to be a father like I said
those feelings they have still remain
but despite the fact that she just slept
with someone she loved for a long time
in both definitions of the word as she
actually sleeps over at the aquarium
she's still having nightmares this one
in particular being unique as instead of
opening the door to the operating room
and seeing her dad again she sees Yara
and Lev hanging this is what causes Abby
to find them again and make sure they're
okay this has been widely criticized as
being shoehorned in as it makes no sense
why she would help these two even though
she just met them but I found this to be
quite the opposite Abby's been dealing
with a lot of guilt since Joel's death I
don't think she feels guilty about
killing him but those nightmares haven't
gone away she only did this to get
closer but as we know nothing's changed
moreover these two kids haven't wronged
her in any way even though they knew she
was a wlf soldier they still cut her
down and Abby recognized that helpful
deed which is why she cares about them
and having them died of the seraphoids
would really put an effect on her
conscience as she had the opportunity to
help them but never did it may also be
that Owen's words are rubbing off on her
she clearly cares about Owen enough to
hear him out so it's possible that
hearing the story about Owen and the old
man caused her to think about Yara and
Lev if we want to go even further
although this is admittedly a bit of a
stretch we could even say that Yara and
love for Abby and the old man for Owen
reminded them both of Joel the old man
was struck over the head by Owen similar
to Joel and I'm warning of seeing that
old man on the ground in pain reminded
him of that day for Abby both 11 Yara
despite being on opposing sides still
help Abby just like how Joel helped her
during the snowstorm now the
circumstances of that are much different
as Joel wasn't at war with them but
still it shows that Joel is a caring man
and not the monster she luckily made him
out to be just like how Yar and lever
serifieds yet they don't fit with Abby's
description of what a serified is to her
like I said the last one might be a bit
of a stretch but the other examples
definitely show how much you are and Lev
impacted her in their short time
together that's why once she wakes up
the following morning she goes looking
for them with the hope that they haven't
died yet Abby manages to get there just
in time and take Yar back to the
aquarium so that Mel can perform surgery
on her sadly the bone is shattered and
she's contracted compartment syndrome
meaning the only solution is to cut it
off furthermore Mel has no medical
equipment so she couldn't perform the
procedure even if she wanted to but both
Abby and Lev agree to go out and find
the supplies together ebien lives
Dynamic throughout this section is sort
of like Joel and Ellie's although
admittedly not as interesting as them as
remember it's the roles of the
characters that matter not the
personalities now that doesn't mean Lev
isn't likable but part one's whole story
was about their relationship whereas in
part two this is just a small piece this
is only natural that part one dominates
in that department I do also want to
clarify something I'm not defending the
game's decision to do this I actually
hate it as it makes it harder to connect
with these characters I'm only repeating
this statement because it's important to
understanding the story just because
it's important though doesn't mean you
have to like it and I personally don't
as Yara love Owen and Mel kinda just
became Jesse and Dina owner Mel do have
a bit more going on for them as we've
already discussed but yaron Lev fell
underdeveloped to me Yara is Just Like
Jesse and that she only shows up for a
few minutes across the entire campaign
and doesn't really have enough going for
her for me to consider her interesting
Lev has a bit more going on and is
likable enough just like Dina but I do
wish there was more one-on-one moments
between them as just like with Ellie and
Dina they are very few and far between
one of those moments though is about to
come up once the two enter this
extremely tall building Lev and the
other seraphites use these Bridges to go
past their wlf the problem is that these
bridges are very high and Abby's afraid
of heights I really like how this was
showcased in game as opposed to just
saying it as when you look over a ledge
the camera pans back a bit and Abby's
face becomes more frightened whereas
with Ellie none of this occurs
personally as someone who also has a
fear of heights I love how well this was
added the smaller details like her
trying to grab onto anything so she can
feel stable in combination with her slow
movements because she doesn't want to
rush through it all and fall are very
realistic and very well done now Ebby is
a much better person than me though as I
would have scooted across this one part
instead of crouching but to be fair if
she doesn't do this Yara will die she's
willing to Brave through the tight walk
across the crane and essentially conquer
her fears if it means getting those
supplies which just goes to show you how
much he really cares about these two
Abby does end up slipping at the end
though but luckily falls to the roof and
into a pool she's alive thankfully but
this fall has caused a bit of a problem
as the bridge was designed to take them
to the other side of the building but
since they fell they'll have to take a
different route a route that just
happens to be littered with all kinds of
infected from clickers to bloaters the
visual design of this section was Top
Notch and definitely up there is one of
my favorites in part two it's basically
a giant building that's crumbling from
the inside the floors don't connect
cordyceps spores are everywhere and the
only way to Traverse is to go down it's
something that was desperately missing
from this game as most of our journey
has taken place outside and while those
environments did look good I did miss
the thrill of going straight through a
nest of infected always wondering what
wall they were going to come out of next
the building's exit just happens to be
right next to the hospital which is very
convenient but this Hospital may seem
familiar as it's the same one we just
went through as Ellie this should be
good for Abby since we know that the wlf
are stationed here but she's still
considered a wall and can't just Waltz
right in Abby also has to leave Lev
behind for the time being as he still
dressed like a seraphite I really like
the decision to make Abby do this solo
because it further intensifies the fight
that's about to happen as this hospital
is Ground Zero for the entire infection
some of the earliest cases of cordyceps
at least within the state originated
here and that infection started 25 years
ago an infection that gets worse with
time
foreign
this is our final infected and easily
the biggest one we've seen all series
called the racking strangely enough this
is not a new infected but rather
multiple infected turned into one large
monster The Mechanics for the fight are
also connected to this as defeating it
doesn't mean just shooting it until it
dies as at one point it becomes too weak
to hold the infected together causing
some to split off and attack you
alongside the Rat King it seems like all
men are of infected are a part of this
thing making this a terrifying Beast to
go up against the fight is incredibly
difficult as well which makes sense
given how big it is I must have died at
least five times trying to kill this
thing it one shots you pretty much every
time you fight it and eats those dollar
store-ass bullets we have like it's
nothing there isn't an in-game reason as
to how the Rat King exists to my
knowledge but it's safe to assume that
the cordyceps That Grew From the various
infected down here eventually connected
causing it to take a different form this
would not only require a lot of infected
but a lot of time which is why we've
only found one of these things so far
and it's located here at Ground Zero
defeating the ranking though does give
Abby the chance to find the medical
supplies in peace and once she goes
outside rendezvous with Lev and makes
her way back to the aquarium with the
supplies in hand we finish day two
overall the first two days of Abby's
campaign were pretty okay I think day
two was much better than day one as the
first day focused on getting us familiar
with people who are already dead and
then spent the rest of that time forcing
us into combat day two is really where
the story starts to take off as the
focus is centered on live and Abby
naughty dog really needed to make sure
the first day was great as it's already
starting off on the wrong foot by making
us play as Abby but nothing of
importance happens that day minus the
interactions with Yar and Lev at the end
of the chapter three hours in and needed
to blow people out of the water from the
get-go but all it did was make a small
Splash if you are willing to put up with
it though the second day will help take
some of that distaste and discuss you
may have for the story off your
shoulders for me I was already invested
despite the slow start because I wanted
to see where naughty dog was going with
this campaign because they clearly had
something planned this isn't just
something you throw together in a couple
months months Abby's campaign was likely
a part of the first draft so it's clear
that they built the game around this
idea so I was willing to play fetch with
them if it meant that I got that treat
afterwards as always though my main
issue is still the length I think Abby's
campaign may have gone over a lot better
with fans if the length wasn't as long
as the previous campaign Ellie is a fine
character to have a lengthy campaign for
same with Joel I mean already played a
show for 12 hours and that didn't bother
me and playing as Ellie wouldn't have
bothered me either but it's due to part
two not filling in that time with
anything outside of repetitive gameplay
encounters that caused me to lose
interest Abby's campaign doesn't change
the mold despite the fact that it needed
to and I think forcing the player to
play just as long as Ellie with similar
repetition was a slap in the face after
this is Seattle day 3 arguably the most
important day for Abby is the growth she
shows throughout this day is rather
impressive and naughty dog does this
once again by using subtlety at the
beginning of the day Lev calls Abby wolf
as that's a nickname the wlf have but
now he starts to call her Abby it shows
that he's starting to slowly trust her
plus their journey together allowed the
two to work as a team and trust each
other even more Abby also lets Lev
become acquainted with Alice which helps
love conquer his fears love is terrified
of dogs likely because the only dogs the
seraphites have ever seen are the
bloodthirsty hounds of the wlf so it's
only natural that he would be scared of
them but as an act of kindness and also
because Lev helped her conquer her fears
Abby lets Lev pet Alice that he can
overcome his own you'll also notice by
now how much Abby's attitude has changed
when around live she's really taking a
liking to him in Yara as they've really
changed her perspective on life level
ask Abby at one point why she's doing
this a question many players likely had
themselves to which he says that she
needed to lighten the load she is
mentally exhausted and her mind is
filled with guilt rage revenge and other
harmful thoughts helping Levin Yar
though will remove some of those
thoughts allowing it to be filled with
more pleasant feelings Mel though like
some players though is probably not
buying this active chivalry that Abby's
been doing actually I'm going with them
but not if you come
what
he may fall off relax with these kids
but I don't
there's nothing to fall for
Isaac's top scar killer suddenly had a
change of heart
nothing to do with Owen
right
I haven't always done the right thing
you're a piece of [__] Abby
you always have been Mel is very
insecure about her relationship with
Owen but it's hard to blame her since
him and Abby did just have sex the day
prior she clearly likes Owen I mean
she's pregnant with their kid after all
but she also knows that Abby and Owen
still have feelings for each other
that's why all of this is just a charade
an attempt to make her look like a good
person in the eyes of Owen so she can
win him over again think about the
beginning of the campaign Abby talks
about picking up more shifts to keep her
mind off things which is what Owen was
doing she also goes AWOL and attempt to
find Owen once he goes AWOL and now
she's trying to help out a few
seraphites around the time Owen told her
about the man that he couldn't kill if
we want to go even further it seems like
Owen's been losing feelings for Mel as
once Abby and Owen meet again they talk
about Santa Barbara but Abby declines in
that she can't go because Mel doesn't
want her coming along Owen responds to
that by saying that all of this is just
a mess and that they should be allowed
to be happy implying that he wants to be
happy with Abby that's why she doesn't
believe any of this and thinks Abby will
always be the top scar killer and
nothing more we know the real truth
though and the game confirms this
because Abby has another dream but
instead of seeing the same scene over
again she for first time in probably
years Caesar dad's standing there
smiling this is the most important scene
in the game it's the first Dream she
said that had a happy ending which shows
us and her that she's able to overcome
this grief and Revenge by putting her
time and energy into something else
besides that Revenge
Abby helping Levin Yara had the
byproduct of also helping herself and
that is the point of her entire campaign
it's to show us how Abby succeeds in
overcoming her issues and how Ellie can
do the same Ellie is currently on the
same train as Abby but she needs to get
off at the next stop or she's going to
be just like Abby this is why I said
that the second half of the game makes
part two so great as without this the
game has no message or story playing as
Abby for a long time was starting to
become a drag and we still have about
four more hours to go before it's over
but I am happy that I went through with
it because you come out of this campaign
with a whole new perspective and it's a
shame a lot of people gave up before the
Finish Line even if part of it wasn't
really their fault given the game's
length because Abby's story is
incredibly important as now it's
starting to get interesting once Abby
wakes up and gets into an argument with
Mel Yara comes by to talk to her Yara
knows that Abby's doing all this because
she cares not because she's trying to
impress Owen she also wants to go to
Santa Barbara with Owen and Mel but Lev
refuses this is because the two left
their mother back at Haven and Lev wants
her to come with them but that might not
be possible very early on in the
campaign we are told that the two were
considered apostates by the seraphoids
because Lev cut his hair this is
obviously a very strange thing to be mad
about so either the seraphites really
are that crazy or something else is
going on here as you would expect it's
the latter sea Lev has not actually Lev
Lev is a boy but he was born a girl
named Lily meaning Lev is trans the
reason he shaved his head is because by
faction rules love was supposed to be a
housewife for one of the elders that is
more than enough reason to leave as Lev
is like 13 at best but it just so
happens that this act of shaving his
head also help with his ongoing issue
which was his gender identity this could
also be why Lev is so particular about
names when Abby and him go to the
hospital alone Abby constantly says the
word scarves in reference to the
seraphites level corrector each time she
she does this to a point where Abby
corrects herself without Lev's
assistance scar is a term used to vilify
the seraphites where a seraphite is
their actual name given that Lev has a
different name than the one he was given
at Birth it's possible that this is the
reason why he's very adamant about using
the proper name for things as for this
reveal I like the way it was handled as
it felt natural the game was never in
your face about these details and it
felt like it was handled quite well I
know quite a few people had an issue
with a trans character being in the game
but I don't see the problem with it
getting back on track once they realize
love left for the island Abby and your
are chased after him the plan is to get
a boat from the marina and take it to
the island once they make it near the
dock though sniper shots can be heard so
Abby continues on alone apparently this
sniper is a lot closer than I thought is
when Abby walks onto the road she almost
gets her head taken off if not for Manny
jumping in to save her many is here
because Isaac and the wlf plan to hit
the island tonight which of course was
the plan he told us a few days ago but
to do that they need the boats the same
ones we're trying to get Abby doesn't
tell Manny why she needs one but he
trusts her enough not to ask but to get
there they're gonna have to take out the
sniper anyway this is very similar to
the sniper sequence from the last game
but it's much longer in both length and
width and there's some new additions
like a ton of infected polluting the
path meaning we'll have to kill the
infected while also keeping our heads
down I've always liked when developers
repurpose old encounters like this as
they have much more knowledge on how to
handle it this time around part 2 pretty
much took what was great about the
original and expands on it the only
thing they didn't add is the ability to
kill the sniper early this bothered me
in the last game since you could very
easily line up a shot if you were
careful and it's even more of an
annoyance here in part 2 as there are
numerous times you can kill the sniper
only for the game to basically cheat you
out of a kill like in this example where
I got one shot when I got too close
despite the fact that the bullets don't
do nearly as much damage as this now I
know why this stuff exists especially
here in part two because the devs
clearly have something planned and don't
want it to be skipped because we took an
alternative approach to the encounter
but I still think it would have been
cool to have
now to be fair this would have only
worked in part one because the sniper in
part 2 is Tommy and killing him now
would break the continuity of the story
so as I said I can understand why we
can't kill him now plus killing him
early would mean we get to miss the most
surprising death of the game as Tommy
domes Manny while the two are pushing
the door open Abby has no time to
reminisce though and has to push on
until she and Tommy exchange blows
before jar comes by and saves her this
Harkens back to one of my earlier
comments about Tommy having a much more
prominent role in this game which I
appreciated as he's really causing
trouble for the wlf here and he's doing
it all on his own I remember going
through this encounter and thinking who
is this guy before I got closer and
realized wait a minute that's Tommy now
I kind of spoiled it for myself when I
went the wrong way and he put a sniper
around through my chest but you may have
also caught on to this yourself as in
that flashback with Tommy he teaches
Ellie to shoot at certain objects since
the infected are attracted to noise
which is how Tommy Lou the infected to
us in the parking garage it was an
absolutely brilliant callback to that
scene it really shows how much attention
to detail Naughty Dog puts into their
games once Abby throws Tommy off the
pier her take a boat to the island and
we can see that the war is starting to
begin minus a few important cutscenes
this whole section is just an hour and a
half of straight gameplay but it was
actually one of the few times I didn't
mind it as the sheer spectacle of this
whole area as the fire engulfs the
Hudson long houses while each side
battles each other to finally settle the
dispute once and for all was extremely
captivating
I just couldn't help but feel awestruck
every time I passed through a new
section of his burn down Island just
like that building we traversed earlier
I felt like these kinds of things were
missing from this game as a lot of our
journey has been through ravaged and
overgrown streets and buildings part one
admittedly suffered from this too but it
also switched up locations throughout
the game as we do go from Boston to Utah
so it felt fresh and part two was
inevitably going to struggle with this
thanks the game taking place in one
section of Seattle but this couple hours
were a treat to play through it also
helps that we get some very important
narrative moments here that have to do
with Levin Isaac Abby and Yara will
eventually find Lev hiding in the corner
with their mother dead on the floor Lev
tried to convince his mom to leave the
island with him but she like many of the
seraphites don't accept lives new
identity and in their scuffle Lev's mom
hit the table which instantly killed her
yarn knew that their mom wouldn't be
able to accept Lev but Lev had hoped
that she would eventually come around to
it at the end of the day that is his mom
and while they don't get along much he
still appreciates her for raising him
which is why he's so upset over her
death shortly after finding Lev is where
Isaac comes in as one of the wlf
soldiers attempts to kill Yara before
Abby takes him down as is confused why
Abby would defend his scar and ask her
to back away from him even though Abby
is more loyal to her friends than Isaac
you could still see that she respects
the wlf as she doesn't kill the guy who
shot Yara and she immediately puts the
gun down when Isaac arrives she's
willing to talk this out with him and
even when Isaac refuses and says that
she has until the count of three to move
she doesn't do anything she doesn't
shoot anyone or even move because she
doesn't want to kill any of the wlf but
she also doesn't want Isaac to kill Lev
Yara takes the opportunity though to
shoot Isaac which gives her enough time
to run while the wlf pepper her with
bullets it's around here where we start
to see the wlf and Sarah fights attack
one another and we do have to kill
Abby's old team but the key thing to
remember is that she doesn't want this
she doesn't want to harm any of the wlf
she's only killing them because they
shot first and it's either them or her
and she needs to save Lev after this is
where the island burns down and we get
to see that spectacle I talked about
there are people dying from both sides
and it's unclear who the hell we're even
shooting at and who's actually winning
ultimately the seraphites will suffer
the most even if they win since their
home has been destroyed but the wlf did
said most of their troops here Isaac
said he wants everyone in on this
Mission but he could just mean most of
the high-value soldiers if he truly
meant everyone which I doubt then that
would further reinforce that this truly
is the battle that will end the war we
never see who wins this though because
ultimately it doesn't matter not only
are the wlf and the seraphites only used
as a plot device to influence the world
around our characters but we also aren't
going to be in Seattle after this thanks
to what happens right after as a member
it's day three which means that Owen and
Mel are already dead and once Abby
discovers this she throws up in shock
the scene I think is supposed to show
how bad this act is now that we've had a
few hours to talk with these characters
but this is where a disconnect comes in
in order to see this act as horrific as
the game wants you to you have to accept
the fact that they are innocent people
and for many others including myself
that's not possible all this depends on
how you view the interaction with Joel
if you believe that only the one who
dealt the killing blow is guilty then
everyone is innocent if not then they
all deserve what's coming to them
remember when I asked if you took Ellie
or Dean aside I fully agree with Ellie
each of them traveled hundreds of miles
with the sole intention of killing Joel
even if they weren't too keen on doing
it and only did it to help Abby and or
regretted it afterwards they still went
and helped it doesn't matter who
delivered the killing blow because they
each played their part this may sound
hypocritical given I've spoken at length
as to why killing Abby is not the right
move for Ellie despite the fact that I
don't find her Innocent but if we can
love Joel and also recognize that he did
some evil things we sure as hell can
agree that Ellie killing Abby would be
justified but also recognize that it
wouldn't solve anything this discussion
though will inevitably bring up another
topic that we could go back and forth on
all day Abby's only doing this because
of Joel and Joel did it because he
didn't want to lose Ellie what each of
them did was wrong Joel killed dozens of
people just so that Ellie Wouldn't Die
Abby brutally murdered Joel simply
because she wanted to get revenge and
Ellie murdered hundreds of wlf and a few
of Abby's friends not even knowing why
they killed Joel in the first place it's
all just unnecessary killing but we
don't see Joel and Ellie as bad people
because we're Hypocrites the characters
we hate do all the wrong and the
characters we love can do no wrong and
because this is all fiction we could
believe that and I feel like that's
where the disconnect originates from
naughty dog seems to want you to think
these killings are wrong but many people
see Joel and Ellie as people who can do
no wrong
oh all right I think I've talked to ear
off enough about Abby's campaign and I
sure as hell I'm ready to go back to the
present so let's see how this encounter
ends shall we the same scene plays just
like before Tommy's taken down by Abby
and Jesse get shot this is when Abby
realizes that Ellie's here before they
walk in Lev says what are we going to do
once we find him this if we recall her
encounter with Tommy earlier means that
she believed Tommy was the one behind
all this and had no idea Ellie was here
like I said before flip-flopping between
each day wouldn't have made sense for
the pace of the game as we would have
arrived at this conclusion at the same
time anyway and Abby and Ellie never
meet again until right now so it failed
to create any kind of tension or
suspense that being said that tension
does occur right now as Tommy like Yara
stops Abby from shooting Ellie giving
her time to escape but ends up
sacrificing himself in the process Abby
then chases Ellie into the theater and
now the Hunt is on but we don't get to
play as Ellie this was a very brilliant
decision for two reasons one it forces
the player to fight and possibly kill
their favorite character if we played as
Ellie then this wouldn't mean much we
just kill Abby like we wanted to to do
all game but now we're being forced to
do the opposite plus this removes the
possibility of running into a common
problem that other games may have you
ever played a boss fight and kicked the
boss's ass only to lose in the cutscene
well that can happen as we play the
Victor in this scenario even though the
fight is neck and neck Abby's wearing
down Ellie Blow by blow and will
eventually come out of this on top so it
only makes sense to keep things
narratively consistent as for the fight
itself it's basically a copy of David's
encounter from part one the player only
has their melee weapon or fists in
Abby's case and the person we're running
from is much stronger and can only be
attacked from behind as Ellie will
easily put you down if you run at her I
also like how they changed up the weapon
she uses in each phase and also not only
increase their speed but removed her
outline from the listening mode just
like David
this was honestly a tough fight Ellie
caught me multiple times during this and
even when I felt like I had the
movements down she would still find ways
to outmaneuver me from a pure mechanical
perspective it's a really well done
fight the fight ends though with Abby
punching Ellie before being interrupted
by Dina who slashes at her with a knife
left backs her up by shooting Dina in
the back Abby then takes Dina and almost
kills her before Ellie announces that
she's pregnant Abby was about to kill
her anyway before Lev steps in and tells
her not to many people saw this as proof
that Abby should not be sympathized with
and that her entire campaign is moot but
it's not as simple as that Lev like Dina
is the buried that protects Abby from
going too far that'd be sort of like an
addict in this moment this is the first
time in a long time that she's been able
to see the world differently Levin Yara
changed her perspective on life and this
situation Medina was almost like a test
it's more comfortable for her to go back
to her ruthless and vicious ways the
same ways that led to her being the top
scar killer of the wlf but that's not
her anymore and while she recognizes
that now it's hard to just quit cold
turkey love being here though is a
reminder of what she's gone through and
how much he's changed in the past few
days it's a very pivotal moment for her
as she finally goes against her Instinct
of taking Revenge because she's always
believed in an eye for an eye and while
she did need some help from Lev to do so
so would anyone struggling with some
kind of addiction it's hard to do this
kind of thing on your own and Abby would
have not been able to change had it not
been for 11 Yara that's why these two
are so important to her she wants to be
better not just for herself but for them
too
once again this is why Abby's campaign
is so important as it's showing how Abby
is able to overcome her problems because
Ellie's about to go through the same
thing and we don't want her to go down
that path in fact these feelings of hers
are about to be tested right now as once
Abby and Lev leave we Flash Forward a
few months from now and Ellie and Dina
are living on a farm together with their
son JJ the scene being placed here is
intentional as we can see how happy
Ellie is both of these women were angry
and filled with rage but were able to
find a way past their grief and urges
for Revenge by putting that energy into
someone else the issue is that for Abby
she's already dealt with her father's
killer Ellie hasn't which is why she's
still not satisfied with the outcome of
Seattle and even though she tries to
forgive and forget she can't as she has
PTSD from that day in Jackson her mind
is corrupted with thoughts of that day
and is even fabricating new memories as
Ellie hears Joel call to her in pain
which is not how that originally played
out this is why Elia is so conflicted on
what to do she wants to stay here and
enjoy the life she has with Dina and JJ
but she can't go a few minutes without
seeing Joel's face beaten and bruised on
the hardwood floor but Ellie's isn't
alone in her struggle as Tommy 2 has
suffered quite a bit somehow Tommy lived
but not only did he lose an eye and some
movement in his leg but apparently Maria
and him are splitting up we don't know
why Maria left him but we can assume it
has something to do with him leaving to
go find Abby because of Joel Abby pushed
away lots of her friends many of them
don't talk to her anymore and the one
relationship she had fell apart because
of her insistence on killing Joel Tommy
lost his eye his leg barely works his
brother is dead and his wife left him
both of them ended up losing more than
they gained in their Petty quest to find
closure and Ellie's about to hit this
point too Tommy still won't let go of
the Revenge but can't do anything about
it thanks to his current condition so he
gives this info up to Ellie you can tell
by the subtle movements in her face that
everything she went through in Seattle
has come back to her all the anger
sadness and fear she experiences come
flooding back her mind is going back and
forth on what to do stay with Dina go
after Abby staying with Dina and JJ is
the smart move but Abby needs to die I
don't want to leave JJ and Dina behind
but I also don't want to let Abby get
away this might be my only chance to
find her but does it even matter if I
find her all of it is Thoroughly
conveyed through her sharp breathing
concerned face and Blank Stare
ultimately though it was enough to
convince her as despite her conflicted
feelings she decides to leave that night
anyway
talk about it in the morning okay I have
to finish it
you don't oh Tommy anything
I don't eat them
I'm cute Dina
what
you think this is easy
for you and for him I deal with it
I love you prove it
I can't
so what I'm just supposed to to sit here
and wait for you for God knows how long
just thinking you're [__] dead the
entire time I don't plan on dying yeah
well neither did Jesse or Joel
Ellie can function because of all this
and we know from her journal that it's
even worse than she's letting on Ellie
goes hunting in order to get food for
the family and one day she shot a bear
but the way it died reminded her of Joel
her journal also says quote happened
again got rid of the images pretty
quickly but my skin hurt the rest of the
morning I gave up trying to go back to
sleep Dina stayed up with me when will
this stop she believes that stopping
Abby is the way to finish this we know
that's not true but she can't see past
it and Dina is sick of this too which is
why she gives her an ultimatum if she
leaves Dina and JJ are going back to
Jackson and she won't see them again
Ellie ends up taking the wrong choice
and embarks on her journey to Santa
Barbara which brings us to the final
chapter of the game we first start the
chapter with Abby although don't worry
it's not as long as you think we play as
her first as she's already in Santa
Barbara she came here with Lev to see if
what Owen had heard about the fireflies
was true Lev has grown his hair out of
it and the two continue to still have a
very deep appreciation for each other
they work well in combat scenarios and
will often playfully tease each other
over small things shinza finding their
secret base and radio and ends up
getting in contact with some fireflies
these aren't actually fireflies though
as when she leaves the house the two are
jumped by some Rattlers Lev and Abby do
the best they can but the group is too
strong three of them were able to take
down Abby and saitama over here knocks
live out with one punch the two were
then taken away and we get to play as
Ellie like I said it's not as long as
you think Ellie is of course here to
find Abby but she doesn't know where she
is she does manage to find the boat Owen
was fixing up and she uses some of her
notes to find her next location but
already we can see that she's having
some doubts about this and it was only
during the trip here one of her journal
entries says that she misses Dina and JJ
and that she's questioning what she's
even doing here she continues anyway
hoping that by the time she'll see her
she'll have her answer but sadly her
journey will be cut short temporarily as
she's also captured by the same people
Abby and Lev were taken by thankfully
though she manages to break free using
the clicker nearby saitama is back and
is actually helpful this time around as
he gives Ellie the location of their
Camp the Rattler Camp is probably the
most amount of enemies you'll face at
one time and some of them also have body
armor and helmets making one shots
harder to pull off as we go through the
camp we can see if they have infected
tied up and also have people kept in
cages the Rattlers are without a doubt a
group of slavers that keep the infected
as guard dogs and use the people that
capture his slaves the conditions these
people are kept in are horrible enough
that escapees would rather kill
themselves than be taken back
Ellie would then eventually make her way
to the back of the camp where the slaves
are and in return for rescuing them they
tell her that Abby was taken to the
pillars and even though this section was
very short it might have been one of my
favorite parts of the game having a
striking and unique appearance is a
great way to personify a character The
Last of Us doesn't have the benefit
though of using fantasy or sci-fi
clothing thanks to its more grounded
nature but it's actually that drab look
that makes the other features Stand Out
Ellie may not be recognizable from the
clothing she wears but what about her
tattoo that's pretty noticeable the same
goes for Abby with her ponytail being
her most noticeable design choice and
naughty dog is banking on the fact that
you know this so they can trick you
later into thinking that this girl on
the post is Abby she's got a ponytail
right it has to be wrong we've already
passed Abby but you'll be forgiven for
missing her given how much he's changed
in such a short amount of time she's
lost all her muscle mass and her hair
has been cut she's practically
unrecognizable her one defining feature
is gone so it's a wonder why she faded
into the background during our walk
along the beach Ellie after realizing
that it's Abby cuts her down who then
rescues Liv you can tell that she's
still contemplating what to do at this
moment and even when the blood of her
body reminds her of Joel she doesn't
just kill her she goes over to Lev and
threatens her if Abby doesn't fight her
right here on this beach she'll kill Lev
if Ellie truly wanted to kill Abby she
wouldn't care about honor or the
theatrics she would have just gutted her
on that post like the Sarah fights were
going to she's so conflicted that she
can't even create the moment herself she
has to force Abby to take the lead
personally I feel like if you're this
far in and still can't make this
decision then it's just not worth it
think the prophet Ellie agrees as right
before Abby draws her last breath she's
spared by Ellie thanks to her seeing a
memory of Joel this memory was the same
day that the incident with Seth occurred
Ellie came over that night to apologize
and talk with Joel and her final line
really drives it home
such an [__]
I'm not trying to I was supposed to die
in that hospital
my life would have [__] mattered
but you took that from me
if somehow the lord gave me a second
chance at that moment
I would do it all over again
I don't think I can ever forgive you for
that
I would like to try
this specific memory being placed here
is also intentional because this is the
last time the two talked this happened
the night before we started playing
meaning right when they were starting to
heal their relationship again Abby comes
by and kills Joel this gives us even
more context as to why Ellie is mad at
Abby not just because she killed Joel
but it was right when they started to
talk to each other again she's probably
frustrated at herself and likely
wouldn't have attacked Joel this way if
she knew this was going to happen Ellie
realizes in this moment though how
meaningless all of this has been she
knows that killing Abby won't bring him
back and it likely won't make her feel
any better either if anything doing this
will make things worse as it just keeps
the cycle of Revenge going Ellie has to
do what Abby did find something else to
put time into so that they can heal but
since she left for Santa Barbara the
road is going to be infinitely more
difficult for her to Traverse her family
and friends are dead and Dina took JJ
back to Jackson she's now entered the
place she fears the most
being by myself
scared of ending up alone
Ellie has lost everything and she's
alone for the first time in years
she even attempts to play the guitar the
one thing she has left but she can
barely do that thanks to Abby biting her
fingers off during the fight although to
be fair it could have just been my
inability to swipe the touchpad since
all the songs sounded like this anyway
so who knows
Ellie then decides to leave the guitar
behind the same one Joel gave her all
those years ago and go off into the
forest thus bringing us to the end of
The Last of Us Part 2. it's still a
divisive game and probably will be till
the end of time but it's one I genuinely
enjoyed it's got its problems sure but
it's still a great game nonetheless
which made me really happy because that
means this whole series is top-notch
part one is fantastic and arguably
perfect embarking on the journey to Salt
Lake alongside Joel and Ellie is an
unforgettable experience meeting new
people was also a great way to bring a
breath of fresh air into the pacing as
it allowed the dynamic duo to interact
with more people and those people were
also equally as likable as our main cast
even if we didn't get to be with them
for a long time thanks to this game Joel
and Ellie became some of my favorite
characters in gaming and it's definitely
one of those games that I wish I played
earlier part 2 continued on from part 1
and started off pretty strong seeing
Joel die was heartbreaking but not only
does that feeling of sadness show how
much we cared about him but it felt like
it was bound to happen Joel was not
going to be able to escape what he did
back at the hospital it's just a shame
he went out like that nevertheless the
game starts off great and continues to
do so throughout most of Ellie's
campaign you feel the hatred that Ellie
feels in these moments but you can also
see that she's becoming engulfed by this
vengeful Journey she's becoming someone
else someone much different than the one
we remember Abby's campaign was also
great to minus the fact that the game
was starting to drag in regards to its
run time our time with Abby shows us
that this act of Vengeance did nothing
for her she thought and planned for
years as to how she would make Joel pay
but in the end it did nothing for her
she lost her relationship with Owen Mel
hates her her dad is still dead and now
many of her friends have joined him the
two of these girls experienced the same
thing and basically ended up at the same
place but Abby was able to find this
piece in Lev and Ellie would have found
it in Dina and JJ had she not gone after
Abby I know part 2 wasn't liked by many
but it was liked by me and while I don't
consider to be nearly as good as part 1
it was definitely a solid sequel It's
because of that that I can say with
absolute certainty that this is a series
you should not pass up on I know they
are PlayStation exclusives which does
make it harder to come by but both are
available on the PlayStation 4 and 5 and
part 1 should be dropping on PC in about
a week from now so if you can find a way
to play them then do it as I can assure
you it's one of the greatest series of
all time thanks for watching
if you enjoyed the video then please be
sure to leave a like And subscribe if
you're new I'm glad to finally have this
video done as it took quite a bit of
time to make for now though we're going
to take things slow at least in regards
to some large videos as the Resident
Evil 4 remake is dropping soon and I'll
probably make a comparison video on that
like we did with the Dead Space video
about a month ago as for what we'll do
after well I'll always update you all on
the community post so be sure to keep
those notifications on
with that though thank you for watching
the video today and I hope you enjoyed
thank you to my returning viewers for
coming back to another video and take
care everyone goodbye